Or live that always sounds so fake,
so it was hard to get these things
started,
so he's hard to just just start talking.
Not Hard,
but I'm learning from you that the way
you define things in your own mind.
A language.
Yeah.
Language they use.
The way you define things can oftentimes
shape exactly how those things manifest
themselves in real life.
Right?
Yeah.
You say more about yourself and what you
actually know.
Not Swear.
Mind coaching comes in.
You say more about yourself.
You give away a law.
He did.
He went.
Sometimes it doesn't make sense.
The talking about something and they
saying that they're really positive
about something and then you think,
well that doesn't match up.
So it's a bit like I'm a barking peg.
Pigs don't bog.
It just makes sense.
That's how I defined it anyway.
A barking when I had to throw through
the filter more fuckers.
You're talking about cheap mushroom
days,
I'm afraid.
Yeah,
it's a,
there's a very interesting thing we just
did,
we just did something called timeline
therapy that you,
uh,
were telling me about.
The Joe Schilling told me about Ian
Mccall.
Got really interested in it,
um,
and what you would use if for folks
who've never heard of any before,
but he's been on the podcast before
Vinnie's,
a mental coach and a hypnotist,
and before our first session,
the last time you came on the podcast,
I was like,
well,
I don't know about all this hypnosis
stuff.
Maybe just a bunch of fucking crazy
people and people talk to them and I
mean,
you for sure have seen those
televangelists that put their hands on
people and they'd go into spasms and
they fall down on the floor and they
claim to be curative.
Illnesses.
Hysteria,
isn't it?
What is that makes the Hallux politics
bullshit?
Or is it something going on with some of
those?
Pinkus is a hypnotic state.
It doesn't mean that it's,
it's a positive one,
but as a hypnotic state,
they get this.
Anyone that does that,
I've been on a couple of podcasts now,
went on the two with a cold,
the dash radio story time with uncle
creepy.
And the first thing of that interview is
set.
Obviously a huge tip.
No,
he.
So looking at,
you know,
I can't be hypnotized,
we'll find out.
So.
Right.
You know what I mean?
People love to say that though I can't
be hypnotized,
bro.
Come get me Bro.
I don't care.
Fine.
I mean,
I think we may have discussed this the
last time,
but we may not have.
I think stand up comedy is hypnosis.
They.
So you know what everything is.
These algae,
you're not in a hypnotic state listening
to you,
Nazi state,
not listened to.
Music,
TV,
having a bath,
shower,
rituals,
whatever.
So do you think that the term hypnotic
is problematic because people think that
it takes away control from you and it
puts you into this Netherworld or
something like that.
Can Do.
But I'll hypnosis itself.
Hypnosis.
So you do it yourself.
I'm only a potion of inflammation as my
first teacher said Keith Mayer and it
went to Liverpool football club.
Great Guy.
Uh,
he said that
we're only post one of information.
So we just guide the way and show the
Pearson which way to go,
you know?
Yeah.
It for the ICT said last time,
I don't do for all.
Look at him and on,
you know,
like that.
I mean it's fine if you want to go with
show and you want to getting involved in
that and way,
great.
You won't have sex of the chair or
whatever.
That's okay for me.
Yeah,
I do.
I don't do it for you.
What do you do it for 'em?
I do because I liked people succeed and
I know it sounds cliche and very hippy,
but I love it.
I like people doing well.
I like,
I like he section as some sort of weird
noble side of me really.
I think when people conquer fear,
when people conquer something,
nothing.
There's nothing bad in there.
Well,
I think one of the things that we talked
about when we were doing a timeline,
I was talking about some of my
experiences when I was younger that have
kinda like clung to me unfortunately or
fortunately in and you know,
you were,
you were talking about your own and I
think that when you've had some bad
experiences in your life and when you've
had some things in your mind that stand
out as a very memorable moments and
points in your life,
those things can kind of,
they don't just define you,
but that also can set you up for the
future.
Like how you think about other people or
how you think about other things,
shapes your life completely and having
these bad moments and realizing what
they were and how they defined you now
gives you motivation to help other
people get over their bad moments.
Yeah.
It's just with time line therapy,
which is devised by.
I'm Tad James and uh,
um,
a very,
very successful guy at Saint James
Company.
My teacher work for them directly
calling MCI.
So I'm a direct descendant.
Really have that.
The technique is amazing.
I mean,
I love it and I said to you earlier,
I believe everyone in the world should
do it and that's not a sales pitch by
the way.
That's just my opinion.
You know,
I just think it's fabulous.
people have things going on,
like let's say you've got an iphone six
or an iphone or whatever.
If you don't use the APPS,
keep playing over and over again.
If that's still going on,
they are going to take some sort of toll
on you when you shut them down and
think,
well actually she'll sit down and you
save your battery and memory and the
shapes your life.
You know what?
I've been saying that for awhile.
It turns out it doesn't.
Somebody just.
Some dude just tweeted me.
Yeah.
It's not like a computer where the
computer is constantly has these things
running in the background and it's using
up resources and battery power.
Apparently with phones it does not do
that.
Malacca d fragmentation.
You're on an old computer when you do
frog it that then instead that's my app
saying,
God,
I want it.
I did too.
I used to use that as an example,
but some,
some dude who actually knows what he's
talking about correcting me,
which is taking over Internet.
Oh,
we,
we cannot,
we must plow for it except our defeats
let's say now it's ruined.
Yeah.
Um,
but I think that,
you know,
your,
um,
your own personal experiences is one of
the reasons why you've become a coach,
not a mind coach,
but a martial arts coach and that these
experiences of negative moments in your
life where you've overcome them and you
realize I can help someone else who is
in that sort of same situation.
Yeah,
of course.
It's just like he's just,
it's nice to just say it's a,
it's not that important.
You know,
people believe that these sometimes.
I mean the got,
there is problems that are massive,
you know,
I'm not gonna lie in some things I can't
solve.
I'm not Moses.
But um,
there is the risk things that,
you know,
if you can help somebody out and they
can get rid of it or change the way they
think.
I ego schilling money did sign my
therapy.
His relationship with his dad was miles
better before he passed away.
Isn't that pretty powerful?
Yeah.
Joe talked about it on the podcast.
He talked about it just completely
changed his whole perception of his
relationship with his dad,
who his dad was in his life and he let
it all go.
Yeah.
I just helped him tremendously.
What more can you say that,
that really as a coach me and had said,
you know,
no,
they didn't get a fight with Justin
scoggins and that because of the weight,
whatever her name was saying that his
life has changed since doing timeline
therapy and doing the,
you know,
work with me not just timeline therapy
and not just hypnosis with my coach and
in general because it's multifaceted.
Rarely.
And um,
he said his lives changed.
He,
he's a different person.
People have noticed,
you know,
so that's for me,
great news.
I think sometimes it just takes the
realization of what's been fucking with
you that once you realize what it is,
then you have it in your mind and then
you can kind of look at it for what it
really is instead of this thing that's
playing in the background that you can't
quite identify or you or you know it
exists,
but you ignore it and you just.
You don't.
You don't ever get over it.
Yeah.
He sees he's interested in either a
client the other week called joy.
She's 80 years of age and she was going
to a wedding in Spain for her grandson
and she was beside herself.
She was terrified,
you know,
and we did it.
Just a few things,
you know,
little things to make you consider
different ways of looking at the anxiety
she was getting.
Anxiety is basically a massive with your
unconscious mind is to focus on what you
want because if you're in an anxious
state,
you focus in on what you don't want,
right?
There's different levels of it.
Of course,
when she was focusing on what may go
wrong,
seller saying all this will go into a
wedding is a celebration of two People's
matrimony,
whatever,
and it's going to be nice and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
She wasn't focused on that.
We've spoken to something else.
I changed that and like she was happy
and she went to the wedding and so now
he's got,
I mean,
she's 80 years of age.
You may not be going to Lowe's a
wedding,
let's be honest.
But if,
for me,
the job itself,
what can you say about nice transforms
people,
you know,
and I,
I
adora no,
I know you do.
I really,
you really,
it comes out of you when you do it.
You really do love it.
Um,
it's,
uh,
it seems to me that human beings don't
really live long enough to figure out
what this is.
You know,
I think that is one of the major
problems that a lot of us have.
We have a certain amount of momentum
that comes from our childhood,
whether it's
good or bad.
And we followed that momentum into our
adulthood.
Sometimes trying to hit the break,
sometimes trying to correct the course
and oftentimes using things like alcohol
or drugs or gambling or anything to
distract us from the pain of whatever,
the instability,
whatever,
whatever it is,
it's fucking with us.
And then you get to be a certain age.
You realize like,
I'm barely figuring this thing out and
I'm almost dead.
You know,
it's the last thing.
He's signing all the papers on the year
on pass know we should do.
Yeah,
you definitely don't want that.
But you also,
you,
I think
there's a big thing that people always
talk about,
like living in the moment.
It is a very,
it's a very difficult thing to do for
some strange reason.
Yeah.
Because you know,
you worried about Somara yeah.
Like worried about light around or
you're worried about yesterday,
yesterday.
Worried about last year.
That's why it Easter.
I'm,
I'm not gonna pretend to walk in a
cloud,
you know,
and,
and trying to come in with all these
long statements and write these things.
You know,
it's no one does,
but that's towson.
But that's a problem with religion,
right?
With religion.
To do that,
one of the bigger issues is that the
people that are sort of proselytizing or
the people that are promoting it there
in some ways,
many of them,
especially priests and things along
those lines,
which is why it's so disappointing when
you hear about child sex abuse,
monks,
priests,
they're pretending to be something holy
and special and above you,
which is why they can bestow this
knowledge upon you while they can.
They're talking directly from God
wouldn't know.
Were all peasants in this weird
exchange.
Yeah.
No,
not conduit.
So are they,
you know,
and I think,
I think good get delusions have gotten.
I think a lot of people do.
You know,
and I've met,
I've met you and I'm a fan of yours and
they really enjoyed it.
I think I,
like I said before,
you never had Wim Hoff who I love
Russell Brown,
brilliant.
You know,
in Dr Rhonda,
Patrick and Joe and Ian and you know
that that component and all the fights
companion and I love that.
Me,
I like it the way that normal and I
don't think he,
I don't think it gives us the right to
try and walk them.
Walk.
Uh,
yeah.
Um,
well,
no,
not,
I've been spot if he ties because of
your shell.
Even in Thailand and not black,
I still wouldn't be any different.
Well,
you especially because you're so aware
of these traps that the mindsets,
it is a weird dance that we do in this
life where you're trying to sort of
manage the mind and figure out what it
is that's holding you back or helping
you or you know,
just sort of guide yourself through this
existence.
Nine Times out of 10 your unconscious
mind is trying to help you,
but people decipher it wrongly.
I think it stays.
It's the language that you mind speaks.
I'll get into it.
Understand that to move away from chaos.
Like I said,
we're going to do a technique if that's
all right.
Yeah.
You just
want everybody not to be driving when
doing this.
All operating.
Any machinery here.
We're going to do a technique,
folks strapping,
but he relax,
you know,
and I want to share that,
um,
because you know,
chaos is not easy,
life is easy,
life isn't easy.
You got all sorts of cesium bursts in
burst.
Exactly.
You know,
you can be me going along and all of a
sudden you get sideswiped by something,
you know what I mean,
and can,
you know,
not if for sex or,
etc. So it's about trying to calm the
chaos down and,
and,
you know,
and just get your mind to settle and
give yourself even a few moments of
peace.
Even a few momentS of patient the day
would be,
you know,
it would be beneficial to everybody.
I think,
you know,
that's what I think anyway,
my opinion.
No,
I agree.
And for what it's worth,
I,
I think we could all use some peace and
reflection.
So that's a big thing.
Yeah.
And I think like many of us are in a,
in a lot of ways are a prisoner of doubt
and fear.
Those are,
those are two big factors in a lot of
people's lives and a lot of people's
response to doubt and fear is to not do
anything,
to not take any chances to try to live
safe,
to try to live like very a very
controlled and simple existence,
but then you miss out on experiences to
look back on is that you also miss out
on the the.
There's just living life without fear
doesn't mean there's not going to be
moments where you're scared and and
taking chances because those moments
when you do take chances are you do
something new and it could be as simple
as like being a 50 year old man starting
jujitsu or 50 year old woman,
you know,
starting a martial arts class or
something.
Something like,
I can't believe I'm doing this,
but those moments where you put yourself
into vulnerable positions can be very
beneficial for you.
So it's not a matter of avoiding
everything that causes you fear.
It's a matter of embracing the
uncertainty of life and trying to
experience it with as much positivity
and as much openness and as much with
the least resistance as possible.
Yeah.
Everything was new.
Once
everyone's done something learned
something the first time,
the first time he.
Does that make sense?
You know,
and for me so people don't understand.
Is that a massive,
massive amount of successes you've had
in your life that you thought was
impossible to tie in your life?
Riding a bike for me driving that was
awful.
Driving mouth wash.
I don't know,
I was just one of those things that got
into my head that I was really shy.
Another car I love rubbish.
I love that expression and the british,
I was rubbish at it and I'm so they are
to basically do it because I lived far
away from my kids and now I can drive
and,
and it,
it was something out I to really push
myself to do.
But I think we're all a collection of
successes trying case writing the date.
Right.
You know all what reed,
you know,
telling the time,
these loads are thinking what we treat.
So you're busy kicking the shit
ourselves about what we've done wrong,
you know,
for me,
when I watched holly holm fight last
time when she fought,
she looked shellshocked and I,
I,
that's my opinion.
She looked shellshocked.
Do you think she was perhaps
shellshocked by the last to misha tate
and then jumping right back into the
octagon?
Or do you think that was.
She was fighting a very,
very difficult opponent
both because valentina
is a volunteership genco.
The woman who she fought is one of the
most experienced strikers in all of mma.
Period.
well the sister was on a infusion season
six with us in Thailand.
Yeah.
So she,
she's from Peru,
things lives in Peru,
but now she,
she's russian.
I understand that.
But she still looked shellshocked.
Do you know what I mean?
And,
and,
and I think that's,
it's part of the process.
I mean I think a lot of gems because
it's macho because it's fight in a year
you'd be all right.
And pat on thE back bar.
You did great today.
If you have a demon like this,
it's like you do know whitewash and you
put all your white in and then you your.
I served almost conditioning.
Oh right.
I have got my diet right amman point for
from a weight,
blah,
blah.
My coach says mma bjj is great or
whatever,
or boxing or whatever the sport may be,
or even if it's not sport,
you know your boss or whatever,
and then all of a sudden you put one red
sock in your wash.
Everything goes pink so that little
thought that can infect you.
So you say,
oh,
you might sit there and the loneliest
places I think find someone and lost it
in the changing rooms.
I think that's my opinion of fighters
did lose in the changing rooms to have
one sort of negative thought.
The mind whispers something,
it becomes a shower and all of a sudden
you drag it with you.
Well,
fighter fights can be lost,
but no matter how positive you are
fighting anderson silva and you pee in
his prime.
Yeah,
you're probably,
fuck yeah,
there is that.
That's why I said he's not a guarantee.
Using a mind coach isn't a guarantee
you're going to win.
For me,
it's more help.
Astronomer condition is not going to
make you win,
but it's a massive help you.
Of course it is.
I mean,
I,
I know the benefit of it.
you know the benefit of it because you
did a little bit of hypnosis,
josie and the benefit of it in his life
as well as any fight in.
You know,
liam harrison is a good friend of mine.
Jordan watson,
the other people that have worked with
another people that will work in the
future.
It does give you a of nerves and self
doubt.
Is it massive hole in your boat if
you're going to do something where you
have to have confidence for everything
in life?
Yes indeed.
This one of the things that I like about
fighting is that it's so condensed.
It's,
it's a very extreme situation.
it's sort of like problem solving,
condensed to like one of the most
intense versions of it that we possibly
can experience other than war,
war,
probably being the most intense of
problem solving,
but it's,
you're presenting with all these
incredibly difficult challenges and you
have to figure your way through it and
with a poor mindset or a faulty mind
that you're,
you're,
it's like having a flat tire or having
bad breaks.
It's like you're traveling in a very
precarious way.
It's you,
you have a lot of holes in whatever
method of distribution that your
thoughts and your actions are,
are passing through your system,
your system of life,
like who you are,
the way you think about things.
When you think about yourself,
where you would think about other people
like that shapes all the results,
all the interactions that you have with
people are shaped.
It's one of the things that I've always
said about like a lot of these
interactIons that police officers have
with,
uh,
with people like how many of these
interactions would be completely
different with a more calm police
officer,
a better person who's better at handling
people and how many of them are shaped
by someone who's just not that smart or
too authoritarian or doesn't know how to
read people well or doesn't know how to
broach a conversation well.
Again,
it goes back dealing with something in
their own mind.
yes.
Dating me,
something in narrow mind,
like we talked about limitless,
didn't we?
The movie bradley cooper first takes the
pill and he saw,
he said the chinese lady on the top of
the stairs,
I think she's his lung lady ladies show
you or something.
She's going bananas,
right?
Just going bananas are him,
you know,
talking rubbish and I'm.
Tcc has given him lots of grief and
blah,
blah blah.
But it went beyond.
It all is something that was upsetting
her.
Right?
That's,
that's what you come across a lot in
timeline already in anything.
Rarely is there.
They're actually taught,
they're Not really taught,
people are not theIr behaviors as
cliched nlp,
nlp chat,
but if people are not happy in neuro
linguistic programming,
what is that about?
A maker engineer.
Robin's right.
YeAh.
Anthony robbins and john grinder.
Richard bandler were the first people to
do it.
They modeled a hypnotherapist called
milton erickson,
milton erickson language.
Milton erickson was very,
very good hypnotherapists and very,
very clever on indeed.
So yeah,
and the,
some of that I used some of that,
you know,
but um,
you get,
as you get anything,
you don't understand this,
you know,
you,
you do your podcast energy as you get
more and more into it,
you get a feel of fur and that's what
you do with my job,
wIth the mind coaches they get afraid
of.
But I don't always use hypnosis.
I do use it and it was his,
but not always because it's not always
necessary.
It's getting people thinking,
reframIng something.
So maybe thought of it like that and
move that out the way.
And that's,
that changes people's opinions and,
and come out massive effects on them.
So the more people you interact with,
the more people you apply these
techniques to,
the better your understanding of how
these techniques work.
Yeah,
I rolled a better understanding of
people.
I think you've got to be out at sorts of
people as well doing this gel,
but I think you've got to be at a church
now.
Not saying I'm massively,
no loads of stuff,
but I don't know little bits about
things,
you know,
and I don't pretend to know about a lot
of things,
but he's just about just being able to
communicate with people and actually get
them,
you know,
actually getting them.
People pretty much want the same thing.
You know what I mean?
Everyone wants to live life as,
as,
as exciting or as easy as possible.
You know,
you know,
like I said before,
it's just about language.
It's just about deciphering the
language,
what they're actually talking and not
even really as easy as possible because
a lot of people want a life full of
adventure,
but what they don't want to do is trip
over themselves.
Like if you have a difficulty and Saved,
you're going to climb a mountain.
Right?
I think that climbing a mountain is
difficult enough.
Yeah,
it's hard.
You have to figure out what way to grip.
You have to have strong hands and strong
feet.
You have to have an overall awareness of
your body and balance and you have to be
physically fit enough to build a pool
yourself and climb up this mountain.
If you're paralyzed with fear,
if you are consumed with self doubt,
if you were overrun with guilt,
if your body is just dealing with the
minds,
all the haunts of your past,
that's the compounds.
Whatever difficultY and it makes it way
worse.
That's what,
you know,
people come to me after fights and the,
they talk about the last fight is still
involved in it.
You know,
they don't tAke the positive from it and
I'd say take the ponds and new blah blah
blah.
But I mean,
you hard to say,
well,
it's hard to do rather than to out
today.
Let's go to the moon.
Right.
Basically.
You know what I mean?
So you just.
For me,
he's like just just getting the person
just to sometimes forget something,
you know what I mean?
And just move on and write.
Okay,
that's something.
What did you learn this,
this and this.
Well,
that's the point.
That's what we know when we was doing
timeline therapy,
you know,
there was things you learn from that
situation that got you here.
Got you.
The ufc come and say successful,
stand up on a lot.
He's got your way.
You've got because of them things that
molded you.
You know,
some people do get consumed by fear,
which is why I.
That's why I like to change,
you know,
I like to change the.
Yeah,
there's the,
there's a big problem that a lot of
people have where they define themselves
by their past.
They look at their past,
they don't think they could ever grow
from that.
They think that is who I am.
I'm not losers.
I'm the guy who crashed his car on that
guy that,
you know,
whatever it was that moment that never
did it.
So therefore,
you know,
like money is the root of all evil.
All you have money or they saw your
keynote,
you have to tread on people to be a
success as cliched saying.
Just pop up from nowhere.
You know?
That's a real weird one that comes up a
lot that almost like it's impossible to
be successful
in altruistic that year.
That money is acquired only by stepping
on other people and fucking over people
and anybody that's really big in
business get like.
I read that once from someone who
actually a very smart person and said,
show me someone who's really good in
business and I guarantee you they fuck
someone over,
and I like that as everyday that's,
that's as a scapegoat.
The scapegoat for your own financial
failure.
Closest thing.
The more money you get,
the more money.
The more people you can help.
There's that for sure.
There's more opportunity.
Yeah,
that's what I believe and I'm believing
and I think it's cliched.
The other thing about money is to just
to keep people down.
I think that's that existed.
You know what I mean?
His language to keep people down,
to keep people just there,
to keep them in the place.
Well,
it's also self self prescribe to a lot
of people do it to themselves.
No one's doing it to you.
You just want to.
You want to give yourself a little
excuse for not going after whatever your
goals are or not pursuing whatever
interest you actually have and just
playing it safe.
That playing it safe.
I think a big part of that is what we
were talking about earlier,
is this,
this need to avoid any further pain.
Yeah.
You know,
one thing wanting to Japan is like
you're not allowed to like yourself.
I mean,
you know,
you're not allowed to be not fun.
I mean it's all right.
You gotta have fun and laugh at yourself
and not take yourself massively tissues.
Well,
the things that you want to be serious,
you should be supporting yourself less
than 100 percent.
Support is sabotage,
which has a say in which I believe it's
true.
You know,
if you're not supporting yourself,
aesop mythology,
not only you but you sabotage and
everybody else around you.
And I think people struggle with that be
in being all right to themselves.
You know,
the so easy to shit and stupid and fat
and so easily swallowed that you,
you know,
people be become used to it and then
they want to be a success.
It doesn't make sense.
Now I recently the,
you know,
these people that want to fight and then
he got lost me fight and blah blah blah.
And then you find out what they did onto
the runup or what did you do?
Oh,
I got drunk,
let's say a week before.
Hello fucking surprise if you're not
live in it and if you're not,
you know,
getting,
really immersing yourself in every way
in the language that you speak to
yourself and in the way that you do
everything else.
What do you expect your mind not going
to support you if you don't support it.
That was one of the things that I felt
when jon jones tested positive for
cocaine three weeks out of his fight
with daniel cormier,
I was like,
ooh.
Like he's not even as I look,
I only was anything wrong with doing.
I don't know if there's anything wrong
with doing cocaine.
I just,
I don't think it's a positive drug put.
Some people enjoy it.
some people enjoy drinking.
I enjoy drinking.
I don't think that's a positive drug
necessarily either,
so I don't know because I don't have
experience with cocaine,
but that's not something you're supposed
to be doing three weeks outside of a
world title fight with one of the best
wrestlers in the sport.
One of the most difficult challenges
you've ever faced in your professional
career and you're out doing blow just 21
days before.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Sometimes the most talented take the
gifts that they've been given and just
abused them in a way.
I met.
I met jon jones.
He's,
um,
it's different to say the least.
In what way?
She's just a bit.
It was a dot.
I didn't know it was,
it was kind of only met him briefly.
Why was it.
I might been Russia at the legend that
is a show there.
And uh,
yeah,
he was just,
he was very sort of,
it was all over the place bouncing
around and I just,
I just didn't expect him to be like
that.
What do you mean by all over the place?
Bouncing just a.
He just said to me,
hi blue eyes.
I would like hello.
He's massive from dangerous and I'm not.
I was like,
hi.
I just found it a bit strange.
Maybe I read it with you.
I just found him different.
Let's just say that I just found him
different and I,
I'm trying to read into this and I'm
trying to avoid it badly.
I don't know him,
but I met.
It was,
it was different.
Let's put it that way,
you know,
but um,
if,
if they,
if someone,
I don't know,
you don't know what's gone on in his
life and uh,
you know,
you don't know what's going on in his
life and you could say that about.
Everyone could say that about a serial
killer couldn't.
Yeah.
What are we doing?
What's going on in his life?
It's not useful,
you know,
really.
I mean there is some things that you
shouldn't do and you know,
he shouldn't be doing it,
but these reason,
if you listen to john's coaches,
they will tell you that john surrounds
himself with the wrong people.
And john is an extremely talented guy,
amazing.
It's only like maybe one of the most
talented guys to ever compete in the
sport and incredibly strong mentally
too,
because despite all of his issues with
maybe not preparing as well as you could
when the chips are down,
that guy gets through things.
He overcomes.
Adversity is not a front runner.
He's the one that broke his toe,
isn't a.
That was terrific.
So he's coming and he didn't even
realize that was happening,
that that happened actually in the final
flurry where you stopped shale son and a
more impressive performances when he
fought vito belfort,
vito,
or completely hyperextended his arm and
he would not tap you.
It was for his title vii tour.
Came that close.
Was it for the title?
I believe it was.
It might've been non title fight,
but vetoer came find out that was a
title fight or non title fight.
Either way,
vidor came that close to legitimately
beating John Jones.
That close god fully locked in armbar.
That would have made 90 percent of the
professional fighters in the world tap.
Well,
that's what makes him who he is.
But he put it,
but you couldn't say no to.
It was a title fight.
Yeah.
Jamie just looked at it.
He couldn't say no to some below.
Well he could say no.
You want.
Didn't want us to get
some sort of.
I don't know if it's weakness.
I don't know.
There's some sort of weakness but isn't
say that.
Don't know if it is a.
It's not.
It shouldn't be something you should be
doing.
It's also indulgence.
It's like
he likes to party,
you know?
But then there's.
Isn't there also the issue that fighters
in particular,
especially guys that have a lot of hard
gym sessions and a lot of hard fights,
they have impulse control problems and
those impulse control problems.
I'm obviously not a scientist or a
doctor,
but when you talk to neurologists and
neuroscientists,
they will tell you that there are direct
correlations between head impacts and
poor impulse control is absolutely a
direct impact and I'm not looking for a
scapegoat in my own life,
but I've looked back at some of the poor
decision making that I've done in my
life,
particularly in my fighting times like
back then and I was like,
I wonder if a lot of that was getting
hit in the head a lot.
Like,
like it can't be good to get kicked in
the head.
It's just never good.
Not the best is not good and so if
you've been kicked in the head or
punched in the face or whatever,
any kind of impact.
And that's the thing about football
players.
They're saying now,
is it even a shot to the chest even
getting tackled like someone rams at you
and slams their shoulders into your
chest.
The brain gets jostled around.
You might not have a bruise on your
face,
but your brain is receiving essentially
the same impact as a punch.
Just kinda crazy.
You know,
a lot of people might not like they
split.
It is a shame that jon jones is gone.
Do you know what I mean?
Because he's got to look back on him.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
He's got to look back on him and they
fuck,
you know,
he's also got to figure out what it is
that he took no data.
They don't even.
Exactly.
They have an isolated what he took,
but the whole lifestyle,
it's most certainly an issue and it's
almost like one of those things where
you say you don't know what you got
until it's gone.
Well,
it was kind of gone for a little while,
but not really.
He was always still in the mix and there
was always multimillion dollar fights,
a waiting and then he fought over in st
prue.
So he's back in the mix and everything's
looking good.
He's slated to fight at ufc 200 against
daniel cormier is going to make 10
million bucks.
It's going to be giant and then whoosh.
It's gone for something that if you talk
to people that are experts in
performance enhancing drugs,
they'll tell you that this clomiphene is
what he got popped for,
which is an anti estrogen supplement
that's not even beneficial.
The only time that stuff's beneficial is
a set of essentially when you're coming
off of steroids,
but yet he didn't test positive for
steroids before or after.
So it could have been a tainted
supplement.
It could have been a mistake.
It could have been.
Who knows what wacky shit he was taken.
I mean,
I don't know.
I just think that,
you know,
people forget that they lot.
Sometimes you still to have guidance,
you know,
you still go have a guide and you know,
to just say,
look,
is that the best thing you should be
doing?
Also wants to talk.
So you know what I mean?
It's that that's not going to be high
five and you cause you're going to stick
a load of bugle you nose.
Isn't it harder though?
I think for champions,
because once they like dominate someone
to kick someone's ass,
like say if you find the most difficult
fight of your career,
you fight,
you know,
uh,
whether there's daniel cormier,
whoever it is,
you dominate them,
you win and beautiful fashion and then
you know,
you like,
god damn it,
I am the fucking man,
and then you just want to do whatever
you want to do after that and indulgence
and chaos and yeah,
he did it,
but it comes to bite you on the ass all
the time.
It does,
but god dammit,
it is a fucking story that plays itself
out over and over and over and over and
over.
And there's a bunch of these
distractions stories like the ronda
rousey story is ultimately a story of
distraction.
I mean,
here's this woman who is just a freak,
right?
A completely dominant female ass kicker.
Something that we've never had before.
I mean,
we had like female fighters before,
like you remember christy martin was
sort of a.
So yeah,
like there was like a little bit of it
with laila ali.
People were kind of paying attention to
her,
but no one was paying attention to
anyone even remotely on the scale of
ronda rousey.
But what happens then?
Well,
all of a sudden hollywood opens up
doors.
You start doing movies,
you get all these offers,
you the darling of talk shows.
You're in fucking commercials all the
time.
Everybody wants to kiss your ass and
there's people that are coming up all
around you that are assassins and
they're not getting all this attention.
They're just hungry.
They're not like holly holm.
When she fought,
ronda was a massive underdog.
Meantime,
meanwhile,
she was a 19 time world boxing champion.
She was a far more accomplished striker
than ronda and ronda fought the exact
wrong fight when you're fighting a 19
time world boxing champion.
Whereas misha tate fought the exact
right fight,
standing outside,
barely,
barely engage her with strikes.
Just push her,
push her,
but backdrop,
pusher and backup pusher.
Constantly move,
constantly vary your approach and then
when you get ahold of her account and
she did that in the second round and
then ultimately she did it in the fifth
round and submitted her and that's what
one or the fight,
the difference between someone who has
everything to gain like that.
Someone who is hungry and then the
fucking mindset of someone who becomes
super successful.
Like a Mike Tyson in his prime.
Yeah.
Like just.
You've just started fucking off.
You start believing that no one's going
to beat your ass and then you fight
buster douglas with very little training
and he fucking puts that leather.
Your face and reality hits you.
When that referee standing over you
counting,
you realize,
oh,
this is happening to me now.
it must be difficult.
Any muslim
bez,
but fighting is not easy to say.
No.
It's definitely not.
I mean,
I was talking to somebody yesterday.
We went out to a thai restaurant with
some friends from back.
Brian [inaudible] moves me,
bail my may have come to see our and
we'll just talk and him was talking
about fighting a fight so hard and only
nervous or scared or whatever.
You was screaming ouT you,
you were there corner screaming shirt.
You think in what they telling him
you're in the crowd if you're not,
if you're not zoned in properly.
And it's not easy.
I mean,
you know,
invite as you know,
all of a sudden the defined something,
they might not have been the hardest kid
at school,
you might not have been,
you know,
the most popular.
All of a sudden after a few fights he
just seemed like whack.
He's like John Jones or,
or rhonda and all of a sudden you're in
this loads of money and people are
paying you attention that,
you know,
wouldn't assaults.
See what school and stuff like that.
It's a muslim.
Be easy,
but nevertheless you still got some.
You've still got.
I think that,
you know,
you've got to maintain the rules.
You've got to abide the rules.
You have to have someone who helps you.
I think every fighter,
I mean I shouldn't say every fighter
because some kind of figured out on
their own.
There's some guys that don't seem to
fall into those traps,
but most fighters can use some sort of
guidelines and there's also these
facilitators that manifest themselves in
your life.
These people that want to make your life
easier so they could be a part of your
life.
So they want to bring over girls.
They want to bring over booze.
They want to get you into the club.
They want to.
They want to like,
hey,
this is a,
that guy that he's going to set
everything up for you.
I'll take care of it.
And when they're doing is these guys
are.
They get into your life and the way they
get into your life as by making things
easier for you so they can be a part of
the,
you know,
Mike Tyson camp or whatever it is.
And then next thing you know,
you've got this entourage of 20 people
hanging around you and most of them are
just fucking idiots and don't know who
they are.
And you're paying for their existence.
You are funding their existence and what
they do is they hold doors open for you
and they check you into hotel rooms.
They do all these things that you could
do on your own.
They sort of make it easier and in
making it easier,
they sort of defined what is okay and
then like,
you know,
no big deal.
Just going to go party.
You gonna fuck this guy up.
Anyway man,
let's go hit the club.
And then next thing you know you're out
late at night,
not getting rest.
Your coach is texting you,
are you in bed and you're not because
you're hanging around with these fucking
cling on
and then when you've lost,
they vanish,
they vanish and then you've lost.
You vanish.
And then you've got to pick up the
pieces.
That's as one interesting more I'd like
to do is I'd like to people for me to be
able to hire me,
obviously to be able to talk soon,
you know,
not just use it now.
She was like,
this is on my mind.
Well this,
this and this.
Not to potter a block on before they do
something that's fucking stupid.
Do you know what I mean?
I'd like to do that and I think you'll
do that anyway.
Do you know what I mean?
But I just.
It's difficult.
It's difficult
to make it stick.
Yeah.
Like if you have a good idea in your
head about like,
you know what I need to do with my life?
I need to eat healthy,
I need to exercise.
You need to follow my dreams.
Okay,
good.
Right now that's a.
That's a good thought right now,
but how do you keep that?
How do you make it stick?
and that's a big issue with people that
go up and they go down.
I mean how ridiculous our new year's
resolutions.
How many people have come to you after
new years in there that are going to
lose 50 pounds?
I'm going to stop smoking,
I'm not going to eat any unhealthy.
And then you see them like a couple of
weeks later,
they look great.
Well you're sticking to it.
That's awesome man.
Congratulations by the money,
isn't it?
And then five months later they're fat
again.
And looking stupid and it's so normal,
so funny,
isn't it?
Have clubs go right?
You joined in january,
you get free january and then you blah
blah blah.
And they go god often when really join
in fee and then the jain,
that's it.
New year,
new me january this 30 new year new me.
And then they just like january the
third.
Oh well blah blah blah.
can't be asked.
Or I was listening to this type of least
resistance.
I was listening to a ted talk.
It was a ted podcast.
And in this,
uh,
it was also a ted talk with.
They're talking about time in the way
people perceive time and the way people
perceive time.
They always perceive that they are now a
finished product.
This is like a big thing that people
like to do.
They're like,
they look at themselves like,
wow,
you know,
when I was 20 I didn't know shit,
but now that I'm 30 I got it together.
And then when they're,
do they go,
well,
when I was 30 I thought I knew
something,
but now I know things and they always
want to thank that.
They're done growing,
but what this podcast is sort of
emphasizing is that people are in a
constant state of change and evolution.
If you're thinking about things,
you know the expression,
no one's perfect.
This true.
No one is perfect,
so if in fact you're not perfect,
that means you're considering whatever
you've done that maybe you could have
done better or maybe we could have
handled better or maybe could have
thought about in a better way or a more
beneficial way.
And then you grow and learn from that.
Yeah,
and it comes to the state of flux.
You know,
I'm,
I'm a different person as it was.
I was there nearly spot on a year and
I've learned more and changed and
different opinions.
Nothing if you read anything or you
know,
because with youtube and got the likes
of you,
you know rhonda,
patrick and about tumeric,
the I learned from,
from listening to you and listening to
people and off facebook and I got
tumeric user group because they tend to
cut off rights and before went to the
doctors can't do anything.
Just off the pipe.
Take piracy at one.
Your arthritis from kickboxing.
Yes.
Belly dancing.
Elaborate,
lying.
Don't be sad about dancing,
but I'm some whatever.
Anyway,
that's a real common one,
right?
With the ankles and stuff.
Yeah.
And um,
I,
I just,
the doctor said,
you know,
that's it.
Basically you take policy elmo.
So put on facebook paracetamal
paracetamal.
Liza painkiller small.
So I just felt,
you know,
and you know,
you can't keep taking ibuprofen or might
be saying to jo about ibuprofen and it
causes inflammation.
Anyway,
so I,
I'll put it on facebook said,
does anyone got an experienced
arthritis?
One of my friends,
lee fraser,
can't praise them enough to be honest.
Functionally,
he said he takes tumeric.
So start every search and it,
you'd mentioned it to joe.
We're curcumin.
Curcumin is the ingredient.
So I looked on a human user group and
then they said they think about golden
paste,
which is tumor at black pepper and
coconut oil.
You cook it for seven minutes with
water,
make a paste of it.
And I mean look on facebook,
use a grave and you,
you,
you basically take that.
I've been taking it regularly and
there's no pain,
no pain whatsoever.
So it's brilliant.
It's the same information as you grind
up the tumeric?
No.
You're making it in a,
in a supplement form or you're getting
it from a route you get cheaper.
Get tumeric?
No.
yeah,
the powder.
okay.
So you're not getting,
you know,
you could buy the root.
The root is real common now.
It's really interesting little pool
miracle.
No,
no,
not really shitty supermarket over
there.
I'm not going to slack off or anything
as a supermarket is another one.
Lakh it off talking rubbish.
So no,
the powder works and you know,
you Just don't know the actual
measurements of it.
But say it's a cup of water,
half a cup of tumeric.
You cook it for seven minutes on a low
heat.
So it starts getting into a paste.
You add black pepper,
like maybe two teaspoons of it because
it's an active ingredient that makes it,
makes it 400 times more absorbable and
nobody really.
Yeah.
Wow.
Black pepper.
Pepper green.
Huh?
Man.
Why does it have to be cooked?
I don't know.
I'm not good with send to do.
I could try.
Yeah.
Well,
how does it taste when you eat it?
No,
the best
thing is just like,
what would you either have pain or.
Oh,
that was horrible.
I'm the king of drinking disgusting
things.
I drink a lot of shitty things.
Um,
but he does work.
Tried my kale shake recipe and almost
vomited.
I've a friend who,
I have a friend called,
um,
Nathan Wright and his hands.
He said he couldn't,
his hands were that bad with arthritis
that you couldn't spray deodorants and
he stunk it and that's his words,
not mine.
And then he started taking this tumor it
paste and he's fine.
He says he's coming like an 80 slash 90
percent better.
I mean,
come on.
do you use fish oil and if you altered
your diet,
may.
Yes,
yes,
I do take a lot of fish oil.
How much do you take?
Um,
I take two massive tablespoons of it
when I'm at home because I've been in
the state.
So I thought I was taking five capsules.
We war and was taking ubiquinol,
coenzyme q 10,
but it is a little bit of higher level
one and um,
yeah,
and,
and me makes me,
my,
my friends now
orin has just got this a tumeric and
arnica tight oil type stuff.
Gone.
Three leopards,
lemonade,
liniments that I've,
you know,
see you're going to trial and that had a
massage it yesterday.
Clear up your words or tyler intimate is
what you're saying.
Yes.
Smells the same as tile.
If we explain to people with ms dot
lindemann tie fighters would use for
sore muscles and things along those
lines like wintergreen menthol and,
and stuff like that.
I don't know what tiger balm was a big
one that,
a bit like that,
but it's,
it's what does that stuff do?
It's very good.
Um,
arnica gets bruises I want to share with
you.
Don't like it gets rid of bruises.
Um,
so how does it really work at?
Well,
I've only just started using it,
but as far as I'm concerned,
I liked it.
I have a friend who's a doctor and he
told me that all that stuff like bengay
and I go,
oh,
that's stuff that makes me feel better.
He goeS,
he goes,
it's a topical analgesic and go,
what does that mean?
He goes,
it makes your skin red.
Oh,
it makes you feel like a was happening.
You like heat there and feels good,
but It goes in order for that stuff to
absorb deeply into your system,
into your,
get into your tissue.
He's like,
you would have to get into your
bloodstream and then it would be toxic.
Yeah,
and I was like,
oh yeah,
good.
When you take like one of those,
some tiger balm.
I have these patches that I'll put on,
like if I have a muscle pull or
something like that,
I'll put a tiger balm patch on it and it
somehow or another relaxes it in some
sort of a way,
but it might be psychological.
Psychological are nice.
I like,
it.
Smells nice.
Normal smell,
arnica title.
Intimate stuff your friend uses to
america's world as well.
Yeah,
there's loads his spiel on it,
you know,
and on the ball,
but I just want of these people,
you know,
when I had a massage of it yesterday,
now I feel
relaxed.
Will they say that most of the issues
that people have,
whether even lIke a lot of diseases,
the stem from inflammation and a lot of
inflammation is caused by diet.
It's caused by,
you know,
just eating bad food and not being
healthy into your body has this reaction
to this food and it's inflammatory
reaction.
Yeah.
He said he's certainly not easy.
What fleet you find out,
what gives you inflammation and what
doesn't?
I don't know.
I think most vary from person to person
and most things and you know,
an allergy thing,
the golden pace,
the tumeric thinkers were brilliant for
me.
I can't,
I can't praise that enough.
that's interesting.
And so how quickly did it take,
like how long did it take before it was
like you were really rock solid with it.
We realized that this was really
beneficial for about two days.
Two days.
Honestly.
That's incredible.
And I was,
I was really working for the american
industry.
I was young and you can buy this now.
I was really pissed off because the docs
are went,
oh,
there's nothing you can do.
And sometimes you say to the doctor,
I think I've got this,
that and the other one because they
think that you're self diagnose
anything.
No,
you know,
this sort of like a,
and just start.
And I just said,
look,
you know,
and she said,
well,
it's arthritis,
you know,
you just paracetamal and I think one
one.
And then when I put on facebook,
which is a good tool for sometimes for
getting information like the internet
is,
and he worked a treat and then he got
into this group and yeah,
it was brilliant and it's worked for me
fantastically well.
Yeah,
you have to sort of separate the
bullshit from the reality.
But if you can do that,
you can definitely find a lot of stuff
online.
And it's confusing to me when doctors
dismiss dietary solutions because very
few doctors are really well educated in
nutrition,
especially educated in the understanding
of the mechanisms involved in absorbing
nutrients and what compounds or
accentuates nutrition absorption and
what's beneficial.
There's so,
so many doctors are just,
they,
they poo poo it because they don't
understand that they have no knowledge
of it.
Well my friend,
when he,
when when he taught tumor tumeric,
it went to the doctor's and the doctor
was saying,
you know,
you can take these whatever I think it
is.
And he said,
saved my destiny,
destiny.
Any always have stopped having the.
because he had a regular checkup.
We had gout really badly.
And he went in and then.
And then the doctor said,
he said,
I've been taking tumeric.
And he said to me,
he said,
there's the doctor said,
well our third of that,
but it's not been tested tumeric.
And said that.
He said,
well,
I've heard it works,
but it's not been tested.
So they're aware I think.
I think there are.
I don't want to piss on docsis double
blind,
placebo controlled studies from any
major university that shows the
beneficial effects of turmeric or is it
just probably make any money?
Does it tumeric?
What should you know?
I mean,
it seems like it should,
right?
I mean,
isn't there a massive industry and
helping people with inflamed,
inflamed tendons?
The problem with those things is you
can't control it.
Like if you do a Study on,
you know,
whatever,
fill in the blank of tylenol or
something like that.
Someone created tylenol,
right?
So if you do a study on tylenol and you
so it shows its efficacy,
then you could sell more of it.
But if you do a study on turmeric,
I'm like,
great,
glad.
Thanks for funding this study.
I'm going to go sell it now and I'm
going to point to your study and I'm
going to make a ton of money off of your
study and I can just grow it in my
backyard.
I mean that's,
that's the problem with marijuana.
The plan is a problem with any sort of
spin.
It's a survey.
It's like 100 people surveyed.
I've never been asked about,
we're not talking about surveys,
we're talking about double blind placebo
controlled studies on information.
If they did something along those lines,
like one of the big issues that's going
on with medical marijuana is the
pushback from pharmaceutical companies
that are trying to stop medical
marijuana from becoming legal nationwide
and they they've halted at least delayed
this supreme court's changing of the
designation from a schedule one to
schedule two in this country.
Schedule one shows no medicinal value
whatsoever.
That's where marijuana is.
Meanwhile,
marijuana is passed as a medical
supplement in,
I don't know how many states now.
I think it's like 20 and it's legal in
four or five states now.
It's legal in Washington dc.
It's legal in Colorado.
It's legal in Washington state.
It's legal in Oregon just
recreationally,
so it's obviously there is some benefit
of it medically if all these doctors are
prescribing and it shows massive
reduction in tumors with the use of cbd,
it helps control pain simpson oil.
Yes.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's incredible how much benefit there
is in this one plant,
but yet the pushback from the
pharmaceutical industry is still
incredibly strong because they don't.
I posted something really recently how
much money.
The pharmaceutical.
There was a chart that showed how much
money the pharmaceutical industry stands
to lose.
If medical cannabis is made legal
nationwide and readily available,
it's billions of dollars every year
they're going to lose because all these
solutions that they offer,
there's better,
simpler,
simpler and far cheaper solutions with
cannabis,
especially because it's one of the
easiest things to grow.
I mean a lot of people grow their own
tomatoes in their backyard and things
like that.
Like pot.
All you do is plant it,
throw some water on it.
It's done.
Not in england.
In england,
they won't grow unless you got.
Well,
I don't know why.
It's not the best weather of way.
You know what I mean?
I guarantee you we'd will grow in
england to try and some some lights and
let's try it and film it live and let
live.
How illegal illegal is.
Pot and in england you can get.
You can get arrested.
He can.
I don't know.
I'm not very good with it being
dangerous.
Meanwhile,
nobody's drunk and I've never seen more
drunk.
People say,
god damn you.
People love to drink.
It's hilarious,
but you're good at it.
That's what I'm looking for.
Way better at being drunk.
Yeah.
I think I'm rubbish at drinking.
I'm.
Oh god,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
When I start crying,
cry,
sing,
dance hall.
Just
memory loss,
you know,
the usual,
the usual stuff that.
But you know,
I don't know with cannabis in it,
I don't take it,
but I mean to see what's going on.
I think belief,
I believe that there's a cure for
everything on the planet.
I think we've,
we these loads of stuff that we haven't
explored that the mind as well.
Just stuff to explore yet the mind is a
fascinating solution to a lot of issues
that people have and sinking positive or
thinking negative or worry
and the stress.
And we were talking earlier about
cortisol and the stress response to
literally thinking about something
affects your physical health and
thinking about things in the wrong way.
Affects your physical health.
Yeah,
and when we got we got,
I think we got more things to worry
about.
I think we've got more things to worry
about now,
but they're actually not anything to
worry about.
Does that make sense?
When you look at facebook and you get
model,
the someone's fucking idiot,
trump supporter healthier,
you don't know anything about that and
you start typing something while I'm
doing that.
When you get involved in something or
you get angry about something,
I do it,
you know,
I'm not going to lie and they,
you think to yourself fucking medu in
years ago when you and the caveman was
only worried about if they're going to
get somethings going to eat them all,
they've got something and I think that
might have been easier.
Of course he died of diseases and he
died,
may have died younger to whatever,
but I mean they lived the mall and
easeful life now facebook though.
So didn't even,
didn't have anything to look and they
didn't have comments on youtube.
Like John Wayne Powell was saying he was
gay.
He gets mad.
Yeah.
But I mean I just,
I call it the same.
I got almost,
I was cold virus all for game of
thrones,
which I was quite pleased about it.
I was like,
oh,
I'll take lord various little penis.
Nothing wrong with that.
No,
I know,
but I just think,
you know,
I don't get it.
Things don't guys don't get haters.
I don't understand them,
but don't you though,
because when we were talking about all
these different things that happen in
life that sort of set you up for the
next stages of life and define you and
sort of alter and affect your decision
making process and your behavior
process,
don't you think that a lot of these
people just live very unfortunate
existences and whether it's by chance or
whether it's by bad decision making that
has just compounded itself over the
years.
When you see some of the hateful things
that people posted about,
let's say john wayne parr,
who's the nicest guy,
brilliant guy and multiple time world
champion.
Incredibly complex,
nice.
His kids a great,
fantastic as kids.
So cool.
By the way,
there's a video of his kid hitting the
pads.
you want to see something impressive.
His kid is fighting.
I think she's fighting on the 20th,
20th,
jasmine and jazzy and he sent me this
video of her hitting the pads.
You know,
like a whole,
you know,
the son can do flips.
Oh yeah.
Your family.
They're pretty incredible.
His wife was a fighter.
Well that's.
I went and stayed with them.
They went to that show and not listen
nothing but respect for john wayne pies.
A lovely guy.
And he's got a great sense of humor as
well,
you know,
don't take themselves too seriously.
I know he's very self deprecating.
he's very aware of how good he is,
but he's also very self deprecating.
Like,
watch this.
Let's watch this video.
This is her.
Nope.
What happened?
What'd you
change the screens?
Your computer fail
Thailand.
And this girl's like,
what is she 10,
something like that.
Jimmy in Australia.
Oh,
there's another one.
There's one that I looked at.
There was different.
It was on youtube.
Oh,
she's 13 years old.
Okay.
But my point is,
you know,
there's people that hate on this guy and
they,
they're not.
Well no,
like they're not happy.
They're not looking at him going,
you fucking loser.
They don't like finding a reason why
he's there.
Just trying to find a reason.
I got it.
I got one about math.
A pest say nobody knows nothing slip.
When did you get this?
Just one of the comments,
you know,
and I was just like.
And he was like,
yeah,
you know nothing about hypnosis,
right?
Well,
I'm here and your salary,
he doesn't mean to mean you know
nothing.
You know nothing about derren brown a
lot.
I've only been to see him three times.
I had all thEse books and he's amazing,
amazing guy and I know that,
you know what I mean?
But he just,
just thinking you'll get whatever you
get,
whatever you do.
I deem this like,
I think joe joe chilean said jesus was
great.
It invite him to a party.
You could turn this water into wine.
He could.
Hey,
you grabbed that dad,
don't worry,
we'll bring you butts alive.
You broke your leg a.
Yeah,
go.
You know,
we'll go fishing and catch all the fish.
It was a great guy.
He's still killed him.
YOu know you're going to get,
people are going to hate you just
because it's more about latin than
isabel.
Here it is more about the news about
you.
That is a.
That's a big factor with online
interaction with people where you are.
What you're doing is you're interacting
with their own paths and their own
failures and the vast majority of people
in this life are not living fulfilled
and happy existence of faceless
assassins huntley.
The faceless assassins really like
snipers of nothingness.
Oh,
you mean commenters?
Yeah,
but they're not really faceless.
Right?
Like at the end of the day,
if you get to who they really are and
what's really bothering them,
they're no different than you or I.
They just.
They got a fucked up start in this life
and they never recovered.
That's what most of it is extending into
me.
No,
I've always been like this.
There's a whole video.
I did a on youtube and be the hero of
your own movie scene.
It's very good.
If you were in a movie and the movie
started right now and you're a fucking
failure,
just think about where your life's at.
What would the hero do?
What would you do?
Address one?
No,
my friend warren brown.
What should they yourself,
but he's on a tv show called.
Did they make him double seven?
A lot of white people freaking out
catalogs.
he has bought martini.
Shaken,
not stirred.
Don't care what color he is,
but he was a.
Wore a knee,
worked for them,
and he's doing a show now for discovery
and he's training to be a kickboxer.
He's gonna have a fight.
It just says he's gonna fight.
Yeah.
Who's he fighting?
I don't know.
Yeah.
How old is he?
He's,
I think he's 42.
He's gonna.
Have his first ever kickbox and my
friend karen kettle,
he's training each training and they've
been all over it.
It's a show with discovery.
Was meant to be on it and be the mind
coach for the show that.
is there any video of him training?
Not yet.
Can find some.
Jim warren warren who was on the show
with him.
Oh right.
Not yet.
Sorry.
Oh,
jesus.
Daniel.
Sam as well from england.
Not bad stuff.
It's hard to say,
oh,
it's terrible.
Someone's going to tell him to keep his
fucking hands up.
Look at his kicks though.
Not too bad.
If you stand right in front of him,
will fuck you up your game.
Now he's getting.
He's got to be.
If he's actually going to have a fight
and he's gay.
God,
he's so off balance though,
right when I say that he falls.
It's like you're watching it's
fundamentals.
It's almost like he really shouldn't be
hitting pads here.
If I was coaching the garlic that I
would tell him,
all I want you to do is touch these
things over five years old,
five years old,
so he's gotten better.
Well,
hey man,
that's really good.
Then if that's five years ago and he's
been steady at it since then,
that's really good because he's got some
basic movements down the waste,
throwing his weight into things.
He just,
you know,
tried.
You guys tried to hit things hard before
they learn how to hit,
right?
Correct.
Yeah,
because his friend who was in it in
luther,
that the other detective was warren
brown.
He's my mate,
my friend.
He wants two world titles in thai
boxing,
so I think they'd been talking about in
warren's been helping him and karen.
Karen's been helping him,
but it should be a good show because you
see all of them seem train in and
between movies like is made when we
spielberg the dark tower or something
with where's he going to fight?
I don't know.
Maybe in Thailand,
Thailand and I think going deep.
I know you got to give him respect
rules.
The whole.
I think he's fighting k one rules which
dumps are easier to get elbowed in the
face and of clench and all.
I saw business,
but you've got to give.
Given respect to like that.
I don't like the way he's testing
himself,
but he did a video on youtube about life
and that now he envisioned himself doing
this something new.
I really like that.
I was going to take what I weren't part
of the show.
I really wanted to do that.
I.
I was gutted,
gutted
word you just said.
What did you say?
It's part and parcel.
That's what I kept saying last time I
was a upset guilted.
You were upset because I went,
what was it was going to be part of the
show is a mind coach,
you know,
because fighters have coaches now.
But anyway,
logistically didn't and stuff like that,
but I mean I wish him all the best and
karen and everyone on the show,
it would be brilliant.
So who's coachIng him?
Kiran kettle.
Oh,
from csa know karen.
Korean.
Okay.
Karen.
Karen cattle east from england.
Kurian from csa is a irish gentleman,
right?
What is his last syrian he's carrying?
Carrying.
I don't know.
I forget his last name was.
He thinks gibbons?
Yeah.
Fitsgibbons.
He's a good coach.
He coaches.
Aila doesn't eat.
And um,
Kevin Ross has a good culture in gust on
bellarmine.
Yeah.
Very good.
Have you seen the fight between
mohammed,
uriah in northern venmo?
No.
Can you flush your right now if we just
spell it out?
A curator isj a r a y aj
a r a y a v ben meaux,
b a n m o h he's only just watched the
third round at his face.
He didn't get a word that I could tell.
I spelled it out slowly.
J a r a y a versus bevmo b e n m o hate.
I'm writing it with my finger.
Oh,
what'd you say?
Yeah,
the moroccan.
Did you say h or h?
Why say hey?
change.
Because it's how you go see each.
Yeah.
Hates,
hates you guys do that too with z.
Say zed.
Yeah,
we do.
What the fuck is that?
We do.
I don't know why.
How did it get abandoned?
Sydney to industry to keep up like this
seems to be some disconnect between some
of the words like tires you guys use or
why?
And color with no view.
And we uncover what the fuck is that
about?
do you have extra hughes lane or just.
Yeah,
we just felt fro.
They said why?
Why is tired t y r e golf august.
Who invented tires?
I think we did.
So you might want to fuck off.
Go now.
So,
uh,
what do you want me to see about this?
One of the best kickboxing fights I've
ever seen in my life.
Really?
Absolutely ridiculous.
It was a last year on infusion.
Much common sense on.
I work for these,
but these two knock the proverbial holes
out of each other.
May 27th of March.
March 27th,
27th.
Okay.
What does mch is that saying?
Oh,
it's the.
Okay,
I see what you're saying.
So in round,
just put round three on.
He got an end with fusion is with an e
folks.
E n s u s I o n is a moitai
organization.
Yes.
In european?
Yeah.
In holland.
And they do in a 200,000 euro tournament
in september the 17th.
But this kid to rise 19
and uh,
it's,
it's absolutely ridiculous fight.
Wow.
Okay,
I'll check it out.
I'm a obviously a big fan of kickboxing
and I'm,
uh,
I'm super psyched that gloria is going
to put on badr hari versus rico
verhoeven if bought her heart,
gets out of jail in jail.
He's not in jail,
at least not right now.
But there's a long time between now and
december.
We'll see a cute.
He makes.
He makes John Jones look like a fucking
choirboy true.
Doesn't mean we here.
We just say,
oh,
it's an interesting fight.
I mean,
for sure barter can win,
for sure.
Rico can win.
Rico's been much more active reach.
Ricoh has incredible cardio.
If you go to the bar,
hurry that beat alistair overeem in the
rematch,
you know,
you go to that bot or the bot or who was
in his peak mean bought her was a
monster,
but it's been a long time and he's not
been very active over the last few
years.
And he said,
what's up?
Switch on.
It's which wateR turns up.
But it's also like all of the legal
issues that he's gone through.
All the,
the,
the behavioral issues.
I mean he's had a lot of problems,
allegedly broke some guy's leg and a
nightclub.
They say it held the guy down,
stomped his shin and smashed his leg.
That's crazy shit man.
And who knows?
Who knows,
who knows what the fuck is going on with
that dude?
I'm know his mom and dad and that real
nice people.
He's a nice guy and still full.
You know,
fathers probably the most exciting
heavyweight.
And he's a wild man.
He's a fucking wild man and he's legit
knockout power.
And the other thing is he throws caution
literally to the wind.
I mean,
he,
he unloads with full power shots,
wade's forward,
throws,
bombs,
like he throws out all ideas of like
being technical and being,
um,
being really cautious and like setting
traps.
He's not setting traps.
He's dropping missiles on you.
It gets to them and say,
I've heard that if a froze up,
I don't think he'd get nervous that he
throws up,
throws up for the fight,
gets ready.
so none of this makes sense.
If you see the way he fights fights,
like it's fucking case.
It doesn't,
you know,
if somebody killed somebody he loves,
that's fights.
He fights like a wilD man,
but it's so exciting.
But rico is a different kind of fighter.
Rico is a very athletic,
big heavyweight who is a amazing cardio
outstanding technique.
His boxing is outstanding.
His kickboxing was outstanding.
Huge,
huge guy.
He's a natural to 30 to 50 plus and he's
in incredible shape.
There's bought her.
The thing about this is the glory of
preview videos to highlight that they're
putting on pretty sure.
The thing about rico is that ricoh has
been super active while bought,
has been dealing with all these problems
and rico's has been getting better and
rico's been beating guys that,
you know,
he had some problems with some guys in
the past and you see him now and he's
just a much better fighter in every
shape way,
shape or form.
Yeah.
When he fell out,
benjamIn accountability fall numbers.
Really.
I mean you spent.
It was sparring with ties and fuel or it
wasn't a good an old decent heavyweights
and beat and daniel geeta who's good.
Daniel geeta farts a good example
because they had fought before and it
was a very close fight,
but in the rematch it was not close at
all.
Ricoh kinda ran away with it.
Rico's on another level right now,
but the thIng about baader is like when
he was at his best and you kind of got
to assume that it's possible that he
could go back to how he was when he was
at his best.
When he went bought or was at his best.
He was a fucking hurricane in there.
He was.
I remember that.
I've seen,
I've seen him because he fought a lot on
it.
Shell time and the moroccans absolutely
love him,
but a bit light geria amateur writers
coming right now and les ballet,
they loved them.
Who was it that he stomped in the head?
Remy bone
gag is when he was on the floor.
Yeah,
he got disqualified for that one,
right?
Uh,
yeah,
I got disqualified for both the whole
thing to a bunch with a little bit like
he was kinda like acting it up a little
bit.
I'm saying nothing.
I have to go to holland.
You're saying nothing
smart on his part.
Like listen to the fights over if I just
lay here for the moment.
Yeah.
It just seemed a little like this guy
who's been beaten up his entire career
and you know,
taking amazing shots.
All of a sudden one kick when he's down
and he just decided like,
here it is right here.
That one kick.
That was it.
It can't go on.
No way.
Right.
I mean,
it wasn't a nice thing that he did.
It certainly is grounds for
disqualification.
But to see him rolling around on the
ground,
like he can't,
he can't function anymore.
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
It has to get swelling was worse.
He did when he was on the floor.
Well,
he's fucking crazy.
Why is he,
why is he like that?
Does anybody know?
Don't know.
I just think he's great.
He said,
nice if me.
It was really,
really nice with me and I'm like,
well,
he's all about.
We make out of cross date.
Yeah,
he's just the wrong guy.
Of course you don't want to fuck wIth
badr.
Hari is.
He's a dangerous,
dangerous man.
So if you want to do this technique,
so what is it you want to.
So basically eight sites,
it's a calming technique.
Okay.
Yeah,
we were about to do this earlier.
We got so distracted to carry on.
You're going to tell people in their
cars to be careful.
Don't please don't do this while you're
driving.
What are we doing here?
And you're using a machinery or anything
dangerous.
She wAs still just unsure.
A basic technique is a submodality move.
So you sort of sub modalities.
Let's go with something that's going on
in the background.
Um,
so it just,
it just calms you down so people can use
it for,
I don't know,
before training or stressful day or
whatever they want to do.
Well,
after a stressful day,
lunches,
you know,
get some time to sleep or whatever.
So self hypnosis technique correctly,
I'm not allowed to share with you.
Yeah,
please.
Okay.
So I'm trying to step back a bit.
so
sit back.
Okay.
What I want you to do is find a
comfortable chair or you can on your bed
or whatever,
and you while you listen to this,
and I want you to yourself just close
your eyes a moment.
I want you to imagine that your in a
room,
this room can be an equally you wish and
in front of you as a window,
the window was slightly open.
I want you to move towards that window
as you go towards that window.
I want you to imagine outside that is
traffic,
bumper to bumper cars,
traffic.
When we know what traffic causes,
when you're in a traffic jam,
you know,
in them situations.
I also want you imagine that there's a
dog running around and barking a really
big dog and making lots of noise.
There's also a modern woman arguing in
the street and I've been a blazing raul
the window next door of the house,
the 11.
They're blaring out really loud music.
There's also a group of schoolchildren
coming from,
but from school I'm making noise.
I want you to notice what you notice
here,
what you hear,
and feel what you feel about the
situation.
With the window open.
Now I want you to start moving Backwards
further and further away from the window
so the window gets smaller and smaller
as you move really,
really bad from the window I went to
allow that window's smaller and smaller
as you go.
Really wary away from the window,
so wIndows really,
really small.
I want you to walk out that room and
closed the door
and just be.
I'm not saying
does it?
Yes.
Skin away from the window.
Get away from that window so that she
could make a bumper sticker.
Get away from the window.
He's just so you just so you just
withdraw it away from the window all the
way from chaos and just quIet and
yourself down.
So now using that as a,
a tool,
like how would want implement that in
their life like that sort of a.
So these,
these loads of different ways of,
of induction into hypnosis is the,
is zillow two different ways with that.
I just,
I just like it personally,
learn off a lady called dolores ashcroft
whiskey and just move away from things
that are going on and just give yourself
like just even a few minutes of just
quiet.
And when you,
when you shut down,
you shut the door and he'd just be,
you can just imagine yourself sitting
and then you can start using your
breathing techniques or just allowing
yourself to just sit just for a few
minutes and see.
See what comes up for you.
See how calm he can.
We were talking about something before
the podcast that I wanted to talk to you
about.
Okay.
Uh,
in,
in relationship to archery.
and that there is a thing that happens
in archery called target panic.
And what target panic is people
that in the moment they start freaking
out and they can't stay calm and they
can't they.
What they do is they.
They try to get that pin,
like when when you're shooting a bow
that you have a site and on that site
has a pin and the pin is it's.
It's set up to where whatever yardage
you're trying to shoot at and your boat
gets cited in and once your boa is cited
In,
you can kind of dial your scope to or
your your site to like 20 yards,
30 yards,
40 yards.
And what happens is people put that pin
on the target,
whether it's at a competition or whether
it's bowhunting,
whatever it is,
you put that pin on a target and the
moment that's on the target,
you start freaking out because the,
the moment that this all is going down
is happening soon.
And people hammer that trigger on the
hammer that trigger,
they jerked the pin offline,
they don't stay still.
They panic.
And this target panic causes bad shots.
And you introduced me to this idea
called hakalau.
Hakalau explained to me,
hello,
how can I always.
I'm from a belief system from Hawaii
called huna eisa.
It's a hypnotic state and I'm nauseous
all the time in driving,
watching tv,
as we said earlier,
when you drive and you don't even
realize how you got home,
you just on autopilot,
right?
Yes.
He just kept no goget.
No,
that's the word.
Yes.
And um,
he's driving it now.
She's basically so huck allow spelling,
hakalau,
h a,
k,
h haitian,
these motherfuckers and there
brutalization of our god given language.
How
about presidents?
Language is hate a k,
a l o is it?
You've got my dad's gone.
The hackle hello?
Hello?
Kate.
J k l a,
u l a u?
Yeah.
So he's,
he's a hypnotic state and the,
it's quite easy to do.
Um,
we,
I've done it with a lot of people and it
works very,
very well to use to calm yourself down a
little bit.
So as I said before,
what you do is I'll just sit down and do
it.
So you're basically using lots of
different ways of doing it.
You can find a spot on the wall that's
higher than your eye line,
so you kind of look it up on a diagonal
and if you imagine that you can,
you're looking for your third eye
looking for the middle of your eyebrows
and what you do is you focus on a spot
on the wall and why are you focusing all
your energy on that spot you imagined
that you can see all the way to the left
and all the way to the right.
Imagine that you can see really high
above self and below yourself,
and then you imagine while you're
looking at,
you can imagine you can use your
awareness to touch everything in the
room so you can see behind yourself,
very rarely above yourself and below
yourself and around yourself.
And what that does is it just,
it calms you down and gives you a bigger
periphery.
It's peripheral vision is increasing
your peripheral vision,
which is extremely good for combat
combat athletes,
et cetera.
And,
you know,
just being calm and just putting
yourself in a common situatIon.
Like we talked about,
bossy allometry young girl didn't
earlier ease and hair color all the
time.
He's amazing.
yeah,
he's a pretty bad ass.
He's amazing.
So explain to me why increasing your
peripheral benefits you like what,
what does it do?
Well,
because if you,
when people say have tunnel vision,
you know,
you'll,
you'll see that.
Why don't you write some of asians like
that?
you don't see anything else.
You see that in street fights,
you see the,
like,
I've,
I've talked about this one street fight
where,
uh,
I watched in front of the comedy store.
These two guys were arguing and uh,
this one guy had zero idea how to fight.
I mean like literally zero.
And he's standing in front of this other
guy and they start throwing Blows.
And this guy literally,
he's wIncing,
his eyes are almost closed and he's
doing this because it may,
it standing square in front of this guy
and is literally like throwing his
hands.
A bus moves in front of us.
I can't see what happens.
The bus pulls forth and the guy's
flattened,
just laying flat out and the other guys
were running away,
so this guy cracked him.
The other guy didn't know what the fuck
he was doing either.
He was lucky that the first guy over by
the bus then.
No,
no,
no.
He just got knocked out on the street.
They were in this treat when this
happened though,
but my point is that you could tell that
this guy was frozen in this moment.
He wasn't aware of this guy throwing his
hands on them and moving his head out of
the way and being completely aware most
of the time in,
in really incredibly stressful
situations.
Your,
your point of vision closes and you
tense up.
Yeah.
So by expanding your peripheral vision,
you think you can relax.
It could be come on,
you come extra law.
What is going on?
When you're expanding your peripheral
vision,
putting your unconscious.
So say you're opening your unconscious
via just like just seeing more than you
can actually say.
So say if you were in a an archery
competition,
you're shooting at this target.
That's like 70 meters away and you
really have to concentrate and you're
looking at that spot and you're like,
when there's all these nerves and
everything like that and you're drawing
your bow back and you're constantly on
that spot.
How would one implement that then?
Well,
you can do hunkeler.
You do that.
You do that first.
explain that so you find a spot and you
find a spot that's higher than the
target.
FoR instance,
say the sockets here,
you'd find it's august.
That's just above.
SaY elvis.
okay,
so you look for a few feet above the
target.
Just find a spot.
Concentrate on.
Just allow yourself to spread your
awareness.
There's also,
there's another way of they get wet.
You can have your palms out like this,
right?
And then when you bring your palms and
when you can see out,
so you can see,
you can see it on palm,
you dRop your hands,
seven.
You'd also put your hand over your hat
and then when you,
when you can see your fingers over your
head,
you drop that to so spread.
You spread your arms out,
you can't see your arms.
And then you start bringing them and the
moment you
see your hands,
you drop your hands,
but you keep your eyes forward so you
keep your eyes focused on wherever that
spot is over your head.
Then you let your hands down and why is
what is going on when I'm doing that
based?
No.
The focus point it just banged awareness
picker.
Just make sure your site bigger.
So when you,
when you're in the periphery.
Yeah.
Have a calmness about you.
And what is the philosophy when they
talk about hakalau in w?
What did you say?
The name of the luna.
Who knows what is.
What is the thought process about
hakalau?
Is that,
is that a part of their practice as part
of that practice?
You do this thing with their arms.
Oh,
well no.
These loads of different ways of doing.
I'm not aware of.
They do it with the hands.
I know.
I just know techniques you've been
taught or whatever,
but I know that you know the staring at
the spot on the wall and allowing your
periphery just to spread.
Yeah,
it works.
And what is,
what,
why is it work?
Like what's going on?
It calms your mind.
And if you're focusing on something.
So if you're focusing on,
I don't know,
whatever you're shooting,
right?
If you're looking at law and yet you've
got this background shit going on,
blah,
blah.
More than likely that ski focus.
It's not,
that's not your focus guys,
the one you're pointing to your head
people to listen to and you're saying
blah,
blah.
You mean like the inner dialogue,
the chuck,
don't fuck this up,
don't miss miss.
Breathe properly,
braised properly.
And when you,
when you,
when you get control of yourself by just
focusing your awareness,
which is your,
your,
your area said,
relax.
then you start.
Then you just get yourself into a
composition.
So say if someone was in a hunting
situation,
there was a deer.
the deer is moving to 30 yards away and
it's moving right into what you would
call it,
a shooting lane in between two trees.
How would you try to initiate haka loud?
Because you do.
Before you Started,
are you to keep.
Practice it all the time.
When did you participate?
Yes,
when you brought it all the time it
becomes a part of.
Yeah.
It's like anything mind coaching or
being been using the techniques.
I teach people these you got practice,
you can't just,
I'll just go,
hello.
And that's it.
And you have to practice it and practice
it and practice it and it becomes,
it becomes more and more.
Yeah.
So this seems like such a simple
solution to a very complex issue.
There's a lot of what is going on with
archery is what's called a.
There's a lot of different theories are.
One of the theories is w recoil bracing,
like you know that something's going to
happen so you're preparing for this
thing to happen and then in preparing
for that thing to happen that is
becoming more of your focus then
actually making it work correctly.
Yeah,
but it.
But it does calm me down.
So even in the aspects of shooting,
I'm surely that,
I don't know.
I don't do it,
but I mean surely it's calming down that
you're aiming for,
for aiming at something.
Right?
So,
but it's also being focused,
completely focused on the result and not
negative.
Just focus your awareness.
Yeah.
the more that you do it,
the more people do inspiring as they get
less hit.
They got,
they get less hit inspiring.
I know where there's a weight lifter
called Emma James,
that's,
it seems like a 20 old time will have a
lifting lady person and um,
she uses alcohol and it works.
And what does she do?
She just basically same thing.
Smokers.
And are there other methods other than
those straight straightening your arms
out,
looking forward.
The best one,
my personal opinion,
you know,
people may argue it,
but you know,
my personal opinion is you say you folks
find a spot on the wall and allow your
awareness just a spread.
So you imagine you can see all the way
to the left and all the way to the
right.
So you're out in the woods,
you pick a spot on a tree.
Yeah.
And you keep practicing and keep doing
it and you will,
it will eventually be embedded.
So why is expandIng your peripheral
vision calming?
I don't know,
it just,
it just seems to calm the whole body
down.
He sees,
again,
you're not full.
You focusing on spreading your
awareness.
You're not focusing on panic.
Are you focusing on anything else so
surely if you're just focusing on seeing
and just moving out and so allowing
yourself just to spread.
I'm doing it now.
You know you can just.
You can just feel it.
WHen I do seminars,
which you do a lot of you doing seminar,
you're talking to people and this,
this and this.
you can spot people tHat are wondering
mentally so you can see them.
Then you just turn it until you
understand and then just go.
Yeah,
because you.
You have to.
You have to guide the audience.
She knows certainly when you're doing
comedy,
I think you do anyway.
I think you'll be doing.
You'll do it in comedy.
I think when you're on the stage,
you'll do it in comedy anyway because
you can become a ladder.
Everybody sort of.
You definitely go into a state of hello
is it induces a state.
When you're doing comedy,
you're in the moment,
but you're also a passenger,
you know,
to do comedy,
you almost have to get out of your own
way,
but you also have to have prepared the
material enough to where you know where
you're going with it
so you can relax.
Think about thinking about archery.
Then you know you have to go your own
way because the only person that's
panicking,
ego,
the animal,
all that,
whatever you shoot and exactly right,
he's exactly the same.
You're moving yourself out of the way to
get yourself into the zone way you're
going to do.
Trust me.
Just just try it and if you know
definitely well,
that's an interesting solution to a
really common issue with archers like
tournament archers,
they panic so much that they've come up
with a method of allowing this boat to
go off without them doing it on purpose.
It's a surprise release hypnosis.
that's a hypnotic state.
Yeah.
They have this thing called a hinge
release and what a hinge release as you
clip it onto your bow and as you pull it
back,
instead of hitting a trigger,
you're slowly moving your hand and you
never know when it's going to go off.
He just slowly curling your finger and
there's a little hinge inside of it and
once it gets past a certain point,
it just goes off.
So instead of like hammering the trigger
goes off completely by surprise.
So they figured out a solution to
whatever this thing is that fucks with
people's heads.
But what you think is that if you can do
It in practice,
you can do It in a real life situation.
If you expand
your peripheral vision,
isn't it?
Look,
you know,
like we talked the last time it was
unable to talk about golovkin.
He talks about feeling innocent.
So how he says about about punches,
but I feel this,
I feel like it says feel all the time
and he feels,
he feels,
I feel this,
I know him.
I feel he is an awareness.
The spansion of awareness.
You know,
in english.
You know that when you flip the bird in
english is that it's two fingers,
you know what it's from.
It's from when we had was with the
french or the french,
you know the capture,
the arches that cut the fingers off.
So that's just to say this before.
Yeah.
But that's to do with the to say fuck
off.
I've got my two fingers and that's from
archer.
That makeS sense.
But it's not a state.
Do you know the mongols didn't use it
that way.
They use their thumb,
they hook it with their thumb and then
they grabbed their finger like this and
they pull it back.
That way they had their own little weird
because you have a release in your hand.
You do it this way because you can get a
consistent anchor point.
So it's running your chin.
If you drop the ball,
if you drop the boat,
the arrow drops.
Yes.
Certainly.
Yeah.
I've heard that one year you have to
stay completely still.
Is the arrow releases coming from robin
hood country as a natural thing?
Yeah.
It's just,
it's.
But there's a bunch of different kinds
of.
Bose is a bunch of different ways of
shooting,
like when you're shooting with a recurve
bow or a traditional bow,
you're pulling it back and just letting
it go really quickly,
bang with,
with a compound bow,
you're settling in and relaxing and
trying to stay calm and keep the pin
relatively close to the area,
but concentrating on the spot and then
you release and as you release,
it's got to be in one smooth motion with
your hand pulls back as you do it.
So there's no yanking this way of
pulling that way or there's nothing
that's gonna affect the travel of the
arrow
level that there's a lot of minDset
going into a level of self trust.
Isn't aware that there's a big level of
self trust and not saying anything small
or anything else.
He said,
learning to trust yourself and trusting
your,
trusting your mind.
You know,
and,
and I just think that with,
with mine coaching stuff,
with techniques that you know,
that you get to learn and get to,
to having your locker,
I think it's massively beneficial as
you're alive.
You will do it.
I mean if you,
you know,
I can always record something and send
you it before you go to this thing that
you're doing and see what happens.
I'd be interesting for me to see what
happens because I've never worked with
anyone in the zone archery.
It is.
It is a lot of preparation for one
moment.
Might happen once a year and that's one
of the big things about it is like when
someone prepares for like a bow hunt in
particular,
the lease a tournament,
you have multiple shots,
you can shoot many,
many times you get more relaxed,
but when someone prepares for a hunt,
you are preparing year round.
You're shooting arrows constantly.
It's,
it's,
it's an.
I can't believe how hard it is.
I mean when I first started doing and I
was like,
what's the big deal?
You stand there,
you keep your arms straight,
you pull the bow back.
No,
there's a lot going on and there's so
much to consider.
The position,
the placement of your feet,
the position of your front shoulder,
how you're gripping the bow,
pulling back to the same consistent
anchor point,
looking through the peep site correctly,
Make sure you send her the peep site
with the site housing on the bow
releasing with no movement whatsoever,
making sure that everything is done
perfectly and keeping the mind
concentrating specifically on a spot.
You have to look where you want to hit.
You can't look in the vague area and you
can't hope you're going to hit
something.
You have to be absolutely convinced
you're going to hit something.
Yeah,
and you will.
You will look at you positive thinking,
you will.
You will,
because that's the intention.
So if your intention set your intention,
set your site,
which is exactly the same as it not set
your sight on right,
and this is what I'm going to do set you
say on your intention where you go and
say,
this is what I'm going to do.
Set your intention and that is a big
part of why people fuck up.
They go,
I hope this works.
This works.
The even said that strikes part,
do or do not,
there is no try.
You know,
you set your intention.
I know it's cliche,
but you know,
we set your intention will a lot of
times cliches are there for a reason,
but they're the,
they're real.
They represent reality.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and I think in this one it does.
It's,
it's just an extreme thing and it's also
a thing of this archery thing and
bowhunting in particular where a lot of
people who are engaging in it,
they might not have a lot of experience
in performing under extreme pressure.
Yeah.
So you don't have a lot of opportunities
where you're performing under extreme
extreme pressure and then you have an
incredibly intense moment where it's
literally life or death to this animal.
Yeah.
But at least we'll talk and we'll talk
because they want you to change the
language around it to give you a motor,
the motor.
Because it is complicated.
I get la please.
We got to make it as less complicated as
we can.
So it's.
So it's a smooth thing.
You said it's complicated,
but it's not complicated like the
english language,
the english language is unbelievably
complex.
Thousands of letters and I mean
thousands of words and you're,
you're using them all in different ways
and inflection and we all do that
effort.
So think I think,
I think you can,
you know,
we're doing the techniques and helping
you out.
My certainly.
Well,
because you know,
you're a very nice man.
I'll give you credit for sure.
I want you to.
I want to,
I really wanted to talk to you about
this because I've seen all these
different methods that people use to try
to overcome target panic and one of them
is um,
a positive affirmation or positive,
a way of looking at it.
Like my friend shane dorian was here and
he was talking about his friend and his
friend right before he goes to shoot the
arrow.
And he said his friends are really nice
guy.
His friend says,
I'm going to fucking kill you.
That's what he says in his head,
Like he says that in his head.
He's absolutely convinced this is what
he's going to do.
It's not.
I hope this arrow lands perfectly.
I hope I make a great shot.
He affirms in in his head where there's
no wishy washiness about it.
When I send intention,
yeah,
I'm a
full and you said you,
you,
you.
And they said,
when you change the language around,
when he changed the language around
anything,
it becomes,
it becomes more useful to you.
You know Lisa Dennis that I said,
he said,
yeah,
it's an affirmation,
but it's also setting your intention in
every way.
If you think about it,
she did not.
Bow is setting your intention and every
single light,
isn't it?
Because yOur intention is the beast,
if you will,
and you're setting your intention so
you've got a calm this.
Yeah,
we'll.
we'll,
we'll get it.
We'll get it.
Well,
I would really like to see if this is
effective or if it helps other archers
because that's one of the things that me
getting involved in bow hunting or been
exposed to this common problem that
people talk about it.
I'm absolutely fascinated by common
problems.
The problems that seem to represent a
pattern of thinking that's really almost
natural,
but obviously should be avoided.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
It's just about you focusing your
attention on what you want.
That sounds.
That'S how you get things in life.
You focus on what you want,
not what you don't want.
You focused on totally on up and you
will get things that will trip you.
Don't live on a cloud and never,
never,
never say that.
What you do is you focus on what you
want and you keep focusing on what you
want and to deal with things that get in
your way,
but keep focusing on what you want.
That's the.
I don't focus on the problems.
Focus on what you want.
Focus on how difficult is this problem
and how difficult it says,
because all of you telling you you're,
you're all you're doing,
you're young conscious.
Then you only formation.
You've given it some harder it.
So then what does it become?
It become something that becomes
something huge,
and this comes back to what we were
talking about,
the very beginning of this podcast.
The language that you use in your own
mind can be very self-defining and can
sort of really not just define you,
but define your future and how you,
how you interact with life and I didn't
tell people I interview are you get you
come across a now you perceive yourself
in order to projects everything into,
into what happens,
you know,
and I think that's the idea if it's,
is just changing the language,
the way you speak to yourself.
if you can change the language ways you
speech of your life will change
exponentially.
That's my change.
The language folks change the language
and obviously this is also,
it's not an instantaneous process,
right?
He's practice.
The first time you did spend in bucket,
you didn't land on the target and was
brilliant like a senior wiley and now
buck.
Well ian's and other british to
wellbeing.
What does that.
Oh well eating.
Well he is a is a wellington.
I don't know,
it's just the slang term for kicking.
Very welli when you kick,
when your well eat something,
you kick in it because you know
wellington boots.
Oh,
okay.
So yeah,
but when i'Ve seen you,
you know,
the senior that spinning back,
kick it out,
usually showing john same per judge.
St louis.
That was right.
You know,
so first time you did that,
you didn't do correctly.
Nobody.
It's all about practice in mind.
Coaching isn't an instantaneous thing
for phobias.
Yes.
Works.
Yes,
but I mean for,
for certain things in life,
you've got to,
you've got to keep doing it.
It's just nice thing is practice,
you know?
Yeah.
And that's the case with everything,
including thinking,
thinking is a skill.
Yes.
I'm thinking of something that you have
to develop and develop proper technique
and adhere to these proper techniques.
Always.
Yes.
That's why I don't do one offs.
I used to do one off,
so he used to be one off sessions for
people,
like one to ones and do a session one
session.
I don't do one anymore.
I do more do thinG called four weeks to
freedom on our people that sign up for a
year with me as well because he seeks it
an ongoing process.
I sTill love it.
My,
my teacher column,
mci,
I still,
I still pull up ruminate things and he
puts my thinking on the right path or
whatever east.
No one's.
We're not a finished products.
I'm certainly not a finished product,
you know,
but it's just about practice.
That's really what's important.
Like people would try to point out
inconsistencies in someone's behavior as
a sign that maybe that person shouldn't
be the one that's being a mental coach,
like yourself or someone who is maybe
not succeeded in everything they've ever
tried.
How could this person possibly be a
mental coach when they're not even
capable of running their own light,
but know that every human being is
essentially the same in that regard is
that no matter where you are,
you could probably do better and no
matter who you are,
you have learned along the way.
A lot of it by failure.
Yeah.
I'm going back as well because I'm
fumbling because he does things that I
think you'll change the face of parks
and I really do.
Why do you think that?
I've seen what he does.
He does like the short test.
Have you seen that or he does the
different numbers.
What he's like,
he's a short test way.
You wanted 25 and they're all in a
square and then they see this.
All the numbers are in squares as well
and he has to touch them and.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
It just loads of different mind.
Stuffy reaction drill.
Yeah,
but he's.
He's building his awareness.
He's building his intelligence.
That's why he's called himself hightech.
He's building his awareness.
He said,
then these next fight he's not going to
get here,
is not to get hit.
What happens?
Was he his head,
you have a pull thing.
He's got.
He's got a mind coach,
he's got a mind coach and when he lost
the salito,
nobody got like where the weight was
wrong and he got punched in the balls
and all that sort of stuff in salita
just out of our program.
Rarely I guess he's too heavy,
this,
this and this,
but he didn't dwell on that.
He went back straight away.
Beat Gary Russell.
He's a great fight.
It's so under each because he didn't
dwell on it because he had a mind coach
saying,
look,
control your emotions mean brian tolbert
of consuMer.
We're talking about.
I read about that.
He was saying that his Mind coAch got
him to not focus just to control his
emotions and that's what it's about is
controlling your emotions,
controlling your,
controlling you,
because you are your emotions after all
and just getting free.
What other People wouldn't and he isn't.
He fighting salito in a rematch.
isn't that?
I think it's muted,
but I don't.
I've heard also that you're going to
move up to lightweight and fight.
Manchester's a sonny terry flanagan for
the Wbl title,
uh,
next year.
Interesting.
But he's amazing.
I've never seen anyone do what he does.
I'm putting out,
which was very good.
Roy jones was very good,
but he just seems to glide around people
and just,
it just seems to know what you're going
to do before you do it.
He's exceptional.
What's exceptional about him is that
he's not outside.
He's inside and he's not getting hit.
Yeah.
That's one of the most impressive things
about him is that he stays in the pocket
in any somehow is so slick and so,
so well schooled by his father as well.
Right?
Yeah.
A lot of people were disappointed.
and andre ward's performance on saturday
night.
I think the opponent had a lot to do
with it.
Um,
I think against,
I think gangs kovalev it will be very,
very interesting.
Yeah.
Well what's,
here's trinkle standing right in front
of this dude.
Just beautiful counters,
man.
It's just so crazy.
Like,
like he's just not there when the guy
goes to hit him.
So he's insane how good he is.
He's so aware though.
He says awareness is awareness is so
perfect,
is distance and he's timing.
And what did he fight for?
A world title fight and his second
profile.
Yes.
Yeah,
and he's won two worlds out.
The different weights and seven fights.
He's just so good at is his movement is
so incredible.
You know,
you see a guy like lowman chenko and you
see gennady golovkin and kova live and
you go,
god damn,
these russians are bad motherfuckers.
Mind coaches,
all of them maybe even the russians
used,
were the first people to start using,
you know,
mental couches and stuff.
This footwork is insane.
And again,
like what's insane about it is he's
right in front of the guy and yet he's
so elusive with his footwork,
who that step to the right upper cut
step to the left,
upper cut.
Just god damn.
He's good.
And he pulls the hands as well.
Pose the hands down and frozen.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
He's really good at that.
He's a,
he's a freak.
He's a real freak.
And so these russians,
they,
that's the way they school.
They're amateurs.
They,
they give them a lot of mind.
Yeah,
they do.
And launch uncle also was doing
gymnastics and ballet.
Ballet,
ballet is coming up again,
isn't it?
You know,
tumeric,
tumeric and so.
Well,
I would think that that would help
because just the ability to control your
body.
Gymnastics in particular is fantastic
for that.
The ability to,
like hixon gracie famously was into yoga
and he was into this very specific type
of yoga that's very gymnastics oriented.
Gymnastic on natural.
And,
uh,
there's a lot of flexibility and
movemenT.
It's more of like a flowing type of yoga
thing,
but it's just the movements and those
flowing type movements are one of the
reasons why he was so good at jujitsu is
because his ability to control his body
was truly exceptional and he had very
unusual ability to control his body
awareness,
isn't it?
It's also strength in weird motions.
Yoga is a big part of that too.
He was,
he was also a yogi and let,
not just gymnastic and natural,
but like regular yoga he could do just
to had incredible flexibility standing
on a balance beam,
standing in a full split,
holding his foot above his head,
you know,
and he's 200 pounds and he's fighting
professionally and valley tudo events.
It'S all mind and body connection
states.
he's getting you in conjunction with
strength and conditioning.
So great as well as these loads of
stuff.
Now this make it can make athletes like
incredibly,
incredibly successful llama llama,
chanko mad gulf kitten matt.
He's fighting kell brook soon in
england.
September the 10th in london aPparently.
Um,
they,
they don't.
A 30 day wayne think and brooks heavier
than heavier right now than triple j.
Yeah,
it'd be good.
Good luck with all that because.
Or should it be savvier?
Yeah,
no,
I know,
but I really.
Well,
because he's english
guy.
I like him.
Beverly's laverty windsor knot up.
Well,
he's got a chance.
He's a professional boxer and he's
excellent.
Gennady golovkin something special.
There's something hit.
His body attack is fucking ruthless to
man that left hook to the liver.
He throws good lord and the way it cuts
the ring down.
And,
and I,
I just liked him as a Person.
He's not the most,
the most sparkling personality,
however,
but I mean I just like him the way he
says.
I respect.
He's old school.
I respect him and blah blah blah.
What's interesting about him to me is
that he's so boyish and cute looking,
but he's a fucking killer.
I mean,
you look at the guy he's like,
and he's like,
I bring big drama fight.
He had been threatened.
Yeah.
Big drama show.
It's so strange.
he had a very,
very special.
Yeah,
he is.
He is.
Well,
so is kovalev.
And that's why the andRe ward five
becomes so,
so intriguing because if he fights the
way,
if andre ward fights away,
fought on saturday night,
going to have a real hard time with
kobo,
last fight against chill amber.
It didn't look all that.
But she'll amber again.
See,
I think it was fighting in Russia.
There was a lot of pressure on him as
well,
you know,
I mean fight.
I mean tony bell for him twice from
england now.
The wbc cruiserweight champion from
liverpool,
which I remember was the only guy to go
the distance except hopkins.
Right.
In recent fights in recent fights.
Yeah.
I mean I think you dropped something
round seven.
I think world will fight on the inside.
I don't think you'll find on the
outside.
I think you'll find similar to the way
for french.
I think that's.
That will Be the plan book.
Great fight of flight.
A very,
very interesting fight where I lack of
award.
His intelligence.
He's so smart and you hear it when he
does commentary.
Yeah.
He's so aware.
Any fights.
So smart.
Yeah.
He just,
he's just a very clever guy.
And everything he does,
he makes it awkward.
He fights different,
almost every fight.
Sometimes he fights in the outside.
Sometimes he sticks to you like glue.
It's,
he's a very interesting fighter seeing
jim lampley.
I'm asking him questions and he,
I think he,
he was an addict,
so have some soul and died really
elephant data.
40 sex.
And his mom was a former drug addicts
and jim lampley astia and you could see
him like,
well open,
you know,
he started crying and stuff and he's
come through shit,
you know,
so you know,
we need.
He's still quite,
he wants to listen to nothing but
respect for him.
He's amazing and he's,
he seems,
and I've not met him at like to a very,
very nice one.
Decent human being.
When he fought the last time when he
fought on a second.
I know his first name is [inaudible].
Second name was barrera.
He won't play where he caught it.
He caught the jap chap coat the job for
a right anD left talk slips on.
Wow.
I mean it was just like,
he's just like,
he's dancing.
He's liking to.
Hearst is fabulous.
Hawk,
alo,
kakao indeed.
Are there any other,
um,
methods of trying to expand your
peripheral?
Uh,
basically practice,
just practice.
So it's just something that you have to
be aware of.
The closing of the peripheral is also a
tightening of you and not good.
I would say so.
But you could still focus even with
expanded peripheral yet you could still
focus on the task at hand.
If you do focus on the task at hand,
he still is still focusing on the task
and hand stride drive is the same,
isn't it?
I mean if he was just driving and just
look forward,
you know,
you wouldn't see anything coming from a
junctIonal.
You still look in the rear view mirror,
don't you?
even though you're not really going to
get,
you're not gonna get more often than
not.
You're not going to hit behind unless
you stopped,
you know?
YeAh.
That's the uh,
the stereotype about asians being bad
drivers.
A friend of mine who's asian tried to
tell me the reason for that is their
culture when they're in asia,
especially in,
in,
in China.
Nobody looks to the left and look to the
right.
It's like traditional to
look straight ahead and uh,
do you mind your own business?
Don't be staring,
don't look off to the left.
And so and also they run Into each other
like,
have you ever been on the streets of
China?
Apparently according to ari,
they just,
people just bumping into everybody.
They just bump into each other.
They're just so used to it.
It's not a rudeness thing.
It's just,
that's normal to them.
So when they get in their cars,
they kind of do the same thing.
It looks straight ahead.
They don't look to the left,
don't look to the right and just plow
ahead.
Was not good for driving.
I was hustling,
I was in Hong Kong and I was trying to
get a flight service with k one.
It was a disaster,
but I was trying to get the flight from
Hong Kong to grandchild this place and
they almost took the they desk
explaining the answers,
get this flight quick.
I was running through the,
I felt like it was intake and I was
wondering about approach and the journey
is just people's barging in front of you
go,
you know what she goes,
I don't know.
And then Jeremy Melendez,
kid who I know from a lives in Hong
Kong,
you were saying that the mainland
chinese,
uh,
miles different than the people from
Hong Kong.
You have a different sort of,
you know,
um,
values and culture,
different sort of.
Well,
Hong Kong was a british empire,
right?
Well still 1999 years.
That's ridiculous.
Why would they give it back?
Oh no,
fuck no,
fuck no.
All toys are made in Hong Kong.
They great.
Yeah.
Well it used to be one thing that
english people do.
They'll say somethIng and you ask a
question.
He's doing great,
isn't he?
The welsh do it as well.
She has a lounge thing.
Yeah.
The wells do though.
I noticed you used to do that a lot.
Well,
you still do in commentary,
you'll say something very complImentary
and then you say,
isn't he?
Yeah,
I see it isn't even that.
So let's just get an agreement.
Unless it's we have julie kitchen over
compensate with a lot or garbage
starrett who would take common site with
your cow that,
you know,
I am asking them for.
It doesn't need reassurance because I'm
insecure.
Insecure thing is a blanket that I need
words.
Again,
going back to what we talked about,
like language defining things.
It's like you're defining the fact that
even though you are observing things,
you are,
you're,
you're being conversational about it and
you're not being,
you know,
you're not like the authoritarian.
You're not like the authority of all
information is being passed.
Are you saying you're looking for a
consensus?
Yeah,
of course.
Because when you,
when you come and say it,
and I know in,
in,
you know,
I'll come commentary is you've got to be
careful with your language.
You've got to,
you've got to engage that,
engage the audience to drag them into
something just in a fight.
You know,
you've got to,
you've got to it.
While I'm bit more spectacular anyway
because I'm a bit high for,
um,
I'm based off,
you know,
a bit squeaky,
but I'm like baker off of violet beaker
off the moffitt,
but it's like,
you know,
you often drug the,
the audience in and I think it's nice.
Chavela is great.
Attack.
Chavela was gray.
Yeah,
he's a fantastic.
Yeah.
It's like a whole litany of phrases that
he loves to use.
Makes you jump.
Yeah.
So you see it makes it,
makes you,
makes you jump as well.
So he'll say stuff that's on his mind,
like swearing and.
Yeah.
For to know.
We're talking,
we're
talking about my friend michael chavela
who does commentary for access tv.
He does lion fight,
which is the premier organization in the
United States,
at least for moitai and the rest of the
world that she aka.
Yeah.
That sold with the sixth liam harrison
fights.
Fabio pinker who soda is the,
a conor mcgregor and nate diaz.
Pharaohs.
Yeah.
That's,
it's to me stunning that moitai isn't
more popular worldwide,
but boxing is more.
Thai is so much more exciting than
boxing.
There's so many more variables.
It's so,
so many more ways to win.
It's so much more effective and it's
just brilliant to watch.
When you watch a guy like sam chai or
yachts and cli or someone,
all the greats book cow,
you watch these guys fight and the
artistry and the beautiful techniques
and moves and also the excitement,
the excitement of more tie.
It's just so spectAcular.
Some sunshine law,
oliver,
but he's like,
you know,
we'd,
we'd.
Liam knows we a big fanboy of lee and he
brings a stone.
Never really.
It never leaves anything behind a brings
a stone.
I don't tell him what a state is going
to be.
Wicked account.
I'm sweating in the hands.
Start sweating and own salsa.
So childish.
I really do need to grow uP and get a
proper job.
no,
you don't.
I'm sanchez.
Interesting too,
because he's.
He's really light on his feet.
He fights different than most ties.
Like he fights on the balls of the feet,
almost exclusively utilize a lot of
front side kicks,
like sort of a hat.
It's like half tepe kick have front leg
side keeps you off balance a lot more,
but ron isn't,
I mean sunshine I think was trying to
originally by a guy called some rock
come sing who won an olympic gold medal
as well,
and he's got a very flamboyant,
sent naked,
amazing skilled.
Does that.
The guY that was supposed to fight john
claude van damme was the one in las
vegas.
Yeah.
Him that was never going to happen.
Right.
And um,
he,
he was east.
So,
um,
uh,
again,
he's aware but he's rock hard as well.
I mean,
you think he's just messing about,
but he's robbing me and I'm watching
again watching him.
Liam.
Liam smashed.
He's from like tibet and he's just had a
counter as well as kicking them as odd
as a coach.
And he's still still,
he's a.
yeah,
he's a very special.
He's thIrty,
he's 36.
He's not,
he's not getting any younger.
He just got involved in a mma.
He's been training.
There's some videos of him doing arm
bars and stuff.
It's interesting because you gotta
wonder like if that's what he's deciding
to do.
And he fights all the time.
Yeah.
That's the other thing.
Like I follow him on instagram and chai
will have this thing like about to
fight,
smile,
fist,
bicep.
He's fighting.
No emojis.
Some of the 11th in england because you
want to again,
kit mentioned kevin kettle and he's,
they just sell.
But um,
charlie peters,
he's fighting charlie while he fights,
you know,
at least six times a year.
Easy,
easy say hey,
fault and gloria didn't he in amsterdam
one.
And that's kickboxing roles without the
clench.
Without elbows.
Yep.
Which is,
it's interesting that they chose those
rules.
I don't,
I'm not a big fan of that.
I'm a big fan of the organization,
but I like elbows.
I think elbows are.
I mean,
look,
if you can kick some in the head why?
Yeah.
Album,
it's very effective when we're talking
about moitai.
Like why,
why,
why limit it,
you know,
why allow like leg kicks,
knees the head,
head kicks,
but don't allow elbows.
That seems to me to be a little weird
thing that one thing that keeps keeps
more tie back is the traditional side of
it,
which I love.
I love my crew,
my crew,
the can on the hand hold it back though
because people,
this is my opinion.
I may be wrong,
but he's like,
you know,
people will sit there and they get the
bear or whatever and they come in and
they watch the fights and then they just
say,
well on.
He said we are a funder of martial arts
so you're not going to really see what
they see,
but I can see it from a,
you know,
what's that?
It's got a nice head for and what's up
music.
Why they done seen was odd and also the
music while they're actually fighting is
a little odd.
But if you watched it you wouldn't hear
it.
I don't hear it.
Yeah,
I was,
you know,
and if you listen for it,
you obviously eric's focus,
but I love it only so great fight is
coming through and in england and
everywhere else and great things up with
will thai boxing council at thai boxing
association at brian dell was involved
in loads of stuff coming through.
she's good.
Your cow and you know and lights said
lion fight him on barlow.
He's one of my friends.
She's fighting a lion fight.
She's amazing.
She's fighting so she will love her.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm just happy to.
Lion fight exists because it seems like
there's so few organizations that are
showing high level more tiny United
States.
I mean if it wasn't for mark cuban's
access tv,
it's like there's not,
there's not any other options.
Mia,
there's some good fight as a gust on
bolinas.
Very gOod.
I like him.
He's great.
He's only other fee for us.
He's rock hard and he think he's six,
six and won.
He lost one fight and it was a very
highly disputed decision law against the
tie content,
but
it's difficult.
I've watched it once and it's close
enough to watch it again to really
solve,
analyze it by like his style.
I liked it.
Comes for his fight and he's only had a
few fights.
I think.
Hopefully you'll be fine.
You'll find in england and soon enough.
Yeah,
and of course Kevin Ross who said very
fun to watch too.
Yeah,
he's.
He's highly skilled and zoya.
Frau is fighting and glory and he's
Kevin Ross has also funny and build
toward kickbox too,
right?
Yeah.
Please.
Just seeing these sudanese last one and
he's still a little bit more tight.
It's very difficult to fight that style,
but I will obviously is.
We have a good gym,
so the transition not transition.
Isn't it funny that the two most people
that it looks like the same thing.
They'll look at it like whAt's the
difference?
And you know the.
The clench is a big factor in the elbows
are a big fan of the stance as well.
The,
the pace,
the stands,
you know giorgio petrosyan,
you could find some way tie style,
but he can eat adopted the rules very
well because of his boxing skill.
How,
what does Georgia up to now he's
fighting soon in ballot or I don't know
why,
because he had that one devastating loss
to devastate you and diversity is
amazing.
production up close.
I've never seen anybody like that.
Just slips shots and just luns and when
he hits,
when he lands with these countless,
they're not.
They're not soft delight,
whack.
You know you're in a position where you
can't hit him and he can hit you.
He's just poetry.
Emotion is absolutely super interesting
too because it is not like some physical
specimen or anything like that.
It's just an average guy,
but she's a very intelligent approach to
finding how color
is eyesight.
I mean these nobody's high site is
because he's so focused on what he does
and even what you're trained in,
everything is specific is a south pole
as well,
which you kind of limit the shots or
what you can at the south pole with you
know our sap or connect you with an
east.
Just got that down to a fine art and
so's marciel.
He says they've got that to a fine art
that the account was at yoga and for all
the,
all the,
they've seen it lots and lots of times.
Whereas if you haven't spotted lots of
samples and spent time with them than it
is difficult for you to adjust to,
you know,
white cubans,
you have so many pass because of the
styles.
Difficult to contend with sometimes.
Yeah.
It is funny that more people don't do
it.
They don't compete as a southpaw.
There's a lot of teachers that are
starting to teach,
like emmanuel steward was doing that
towards the end days was a teaching guys
to fight with their strong hand forward.
So he's taking right handers and having
to fight southpaws.
Yeah.
Well the cutouts are left handed or left
handed off.
A duck's Delaware is lefthanded fight in
an orthodox stance.
So he'd have his left arm,
which is his dominant hand forward.
Andre ward.
He's lefthanded,
but I don't know whether
or not.
It's interesting though,
isn't it,
to make that decision to use your
dominant hand as your front hand when
everybody else uses it as the power hand
the backhand.
Yeah,
I mean,
I don't know,
it feels a bit,
but then again it would feel weird if
you don't do it.
This is like anything.
It's everything feels weird.
ReMember the first time you tried to
throw a left hook,
you're like,
what?
Yeah,
I'm lefthanded anyway.
Sorry.
Yeah,
so he's.
He's always been so always been a right
hook first year,
but I remember first time throwing a
hook,
thinking like what a bizarre way to
generate power and now it's second
nature.
Now it just feels like you just,
you know it.
Your body just moves that way.
I think john wayne pass lefthanded.
Izzy,
can you watch you on every doc?
He's lucky he's left kick,
but he trained with santee and noi for
many years and sanction knows something.
He knows his alphabet.
Joan,
my passcode.
Great.
Left cake.
Yeah,
we're slowly starting to see real high
level more thai fighters compete in mma
and really more so in women's mma and I
mean we have a lot of high level people
in the men's mma of course,
But in women's mma to on jacob.
What am I saying?
Her name?
Right?
You wanna young,
young jay.
Check.
Why am I saying it wrong though?
Young,
young jet.
Check,
check.
Yeah,
but why am I saying it wrong?
It's one of those words were,
if you don't,
if you don't say it for a couple of
days,
you go back to it and go.
You want everybody says yohanna to which
actually you want to young jay check
thing.
I'm saying it right.
Feel off.
It's so different between the way she
says it.
She says it.
You're like,
ooh,
I don't even know if I can make that
noise in my face.
You see why questions things?
See,
here's the thing.
When you look at it right there,
first of all,
what the fuck is going on with that?
Why is that?
He have a goatee like that does not help
me at all.
Like if she's.
If you pull up her name and you make me
re say her name or it doesn't help me at
all,
but whatever.
She's fucking awesome.
Which she is,
is.
She's really incredible like her.
Her,
her technique or jab is just vicious.
She steps forward and blast that stiff
jab on girls.
Her front kicks her round,
kicks her,
her elbows when she's defending
takedowns,
her clinch work.
May god,
she's good.
She's so good.
She's one of the most technical strikers
in any division and she's in women's
mma.
Of course.
Volunteership chanko of course,
very,
very accomplished moy thai fighter who's
now fighting in women's mma.
Yeah.
There's some good coaches coming.
Frivolous.
Bryan pope,
jelly as well from boxing.
He's really good.
I watched him on patsy of the day and he
what he's doing,
he's a good.
He's a good coach.
Go to the elbows and good with timing
and all that sort of business.
what do you think that more time needs
in order to become as popular in the
United States as it is in other parts of
the world?
You a chance,
right?
Accounts.
It's not fun.
It's not as if they got not got decent
people with it.
I'm here because let's say joe,
sheldon and amy can come in here with
you,
which is brilliant.
Thanks very much,
but I've come to see brian doebele from
wls,
my tie and east east full face light,
million miles an hour of everything.
And where's that?
Uh,
in fontana and uh,
in California and they,
you know,
the,
I've got the talent.
It's just a chance.
I actually don't know.
I think he's a lot of politics involved
or you know,
they're not getting the smokers have
been a band,
you know,
the,
uh,
qualified.
Yeah,
we call them into clips.
They're banned everywhere.
California,
I think California,
which is unfortunate because our,
they're going to get experience.
They're not,
but they're also,
they're not going to die.
That's all people were worried about was
some of it.
Some people were being unethical and
they're smokers or they didn't have a
proper medical staff on think someone
got hurt and an mma smoker.
And I think that they kind of polluted
everything a bit loud.
People get hurt in the gym,
the gym in the washing machine.
But I'd love it to have a chance.
I think it should be bigger in the
United States and they need to
compensate from england by the way.
I agree,
I really do think that it should be
bigger than the United States and I do
think that it's not something that's.
It's not like cricket,
like good luck selling that,
but it's something that's universally
exciting.
I know you guys will enjoy cricket.
I don't even.
I don't even know what it means.
I don't even know anything about it.
Congratulations this far.
I'll football or american football or
baseball league,
but moitai is universally exciting.
If you watch it,
it's universally exciting and in my
opinion it's one of the most effective
combat sports and as itself as an
individual unit.
Yeah.
Y'all call.
Well,
I worked for amazing and fusion that I
will,
I,
I'm very privileged to work for them to
of high level stuff.
I love it.
I mean infusion fusion of the best new
commerce,
the,
you know,
the new kids on the block coming
through.
They're amazing.
These moroccans are rock hard and
england,
you know,
with,
with the car when children watson liam
and panic costs and all of guilt guys
coming phrase wicked.
I love it.
Well listen,
I hate to cut this off but I gotta get
the fuck outta here,
but I really appreciate you coming down
here.
Again,
I learn a lot every time I talk to you
and I think people do as well and to
appreciate the timeline therapy and if
people want to get ahold of you,
how did they do that?
[inaudible] dot com.
I can get me on facebook or you can get
me at [inaudible] 69 on twitter.
All right ladies and gentlemen,
thank you very much.
Vinny shoreman.
Thanks joe.
Thanks brother.